showing this would you mind just
um switching on camera microphone to
make sure it's working
the Stars I'd like us to confirm which
committee members are here
thank you chair I can confirm that we
have councilor William Armitage
councilor Pat and Cliff and New South
councilor Jane Barry who is chairing the
meeting today councilor Andrew Cooper
councilor Mark Foster and councilor
Roger Hall Carol Huckabee Mo Potts Alan
Powell Jackie Ridgeway Kathy Rouse and
Ross Shipman we also have Council Anne
Holmes who's in attendance at the
meeting today and councilor um Pam
windsby and we also have councilor Alex
Dale who will be speaking on the first
application and
um we expect accounts for Cupid till
he's working out speaking on the third
application and just to let you know the
officers present are Adrian Kirk and the
planning manager Jim Fields then sister
to the council and then we have Alan
Mark clock to the committee along with
Damon Stanton Martin Derbyshire and
myself Amy Brian from the governance
team will be facilitating the meeting
thank you
as you know we have a 12 to call in
place for the meeting in this virtual
way which I would now like the meeting
facility to read out
thank you chair just to remind members
to keep their cameras on throughout the
meeting and behave as you would in the
council chamber following the rules of
procedure and the virtual beating
standing orders and please be mindful of
your home surroundings and appear alone
on camera to indicate your wish to speak
please raise your hand or write speak in
the chat function please keep your
microphone off when you haven't been
called to speak and when you do come to
speak please introduce yourself making
clear your a counselor giving your name
and what Ward you represent voting on
the planning applications today will be
done by roll calls so I will call your
names in alphabetical order and if you
can put your microphone on and clearly
indicate whether you're for against or
whether you will be abstaining
uh that's it thank you chair thank you
the first item on today's agenda is
apologies for absence have we received
any in advance
um yes chair apologies have been
received from Council Diana ruff who
will be substituted by councilor Pat and
Cliff apologies have also been received
from councilor Tracy reader who will be
substituted by Council Lee Hartson
uh finally councilor Roger Hall will
substitute for councilor PT Elliott
thank you chair
thank you
have any other apologies
a non-received job
thank you
the second item is Declarations of
Interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
peculiary interest and all other
interests not already all their
registered interests in any item on the
agenda and withdraw from the meeting at
the appropriate time
have we received any declarations in
advance
I haven't received any chair
thank you
do any other members have any interest
to declare
[Music]
on receiver thank you
the next item is the minutes of the last
meeting
uh there's two sets of meeting Linux
which are both held on 28th of July
we will start with the minutes of the
special meeting of the committee held in
the morning and we're happy that they
are correct the correct record and is
there a movement
I'll move them chairs oh
thank you
for all those in favor
that's caritra thank you for all those
again
thank you no obsessions
the lotion has been carried right so now
we'll move on to the minutes of the
meeting held in the afternoon are we
happy that again there are correct
record
thank you all those in favor
those against
any abstentions
[Music]
the motion has been carried
thank you
and thanks to members the move that
moves us up on to our main business
today and as you can see with three
applications Each of which has its own
report marked as items before a 4B and
4C I am happy with this and I intent to
consider them in that order
however before we do this I would like
the client to explain to you the benefit
of members speakers and the public who
are watching on you on YouTube how they
will be dealt with
all right thank you chair
um this is the procedure for considering
applications at the meeting
uh as you say we will consider the three
applications in the order that they are
set out on the agenda
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
the late items agenda supplement has
been published on the council's website
the link has been sent to committee
members
planning officers will then give a brief
presentation
setting out the application plans are
photographs from the site
the screen showing this presentation
will be shared with those attending the
meeting
they can also be seen on the council's
website to its YouTube channel
following on from this
the chair will ask each of the speakers
any Ward Members First followed by
objectors then the applicants and their
agents and supporters
to speak to the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their use their views using
this conferencing facility
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions to clarify any points they
have made if that's necessary
when you have heard from all the
speakers on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee
and determination by a vote
a note for the speakers
once the application you've come to
speak on has been dealt with
you may leave the virtual meeting room
if you choose to remain
then please mute your microphone and
turn off your camera
you will not be allowed to participate
further in the meeting from that point
this meeting is being live streamed
the council will make a recording for
the for the purpose of preparing the
minutes
once the minutes have been approved by
the committee then this recording will
be deleted
please note however
that others may also record the live
stream from the internet
thank you chair
thank you
let's now move to the first application
which is Ned stroke 19 stroke zero one
one seven four
flirt delete Hotel Main Road Ulster
dronfield S18 4ab
in line with our normal practice is oh
sorry uh erection of a two-story
building comprising of four beds four
two bed Flats
um classes affordable housing with
parking for suits cars and Associated
Landscaping all within the curse Village
of the former public house for the Leeds
Hotel Main Road Austin
in line with our normal practice I'm
going to ask the planning officers to
tell us about any late comment reports
that have been produced and for the
planning management presentation showing
any photos of Promise of the Sun
the meeting facilitator will share the
presentation off the screen this means
that I might find it difficult to see
everyone so please bear with me if you
want to speak
and therefore I will allow the officers
to complete their presentation and ask
members to reserve any points to the
Border or questions about the process
until the end there'll be plenty of time
for you to ask your questions later on
okay
can I ask the funding officers funding
manager to speak
thank you chair for Amy's able to share
the presentation on the screen please
just before I go through the
presentation chair just a couple of
other um
elements I just want to advise members
of first of all chair members will see
in the report the recommended conditions
in addition to that chair further to the
stated conditions I would ask members if
they're minded to Grant consent for the
scheme this afternoon that condition
three is clarified to make reference to
the application granting exempt for
affordable housing only and also chair
and some additional condition relating
to boundary treatments and the provision
and maintenance of the proposed bin
store are also added on to the
conditions should as say we will be
granted and also chair as is customary
to allow myself under delegated powers
to make any other minor changes in
drafting that may be considered
appropriate prior to the issuing of the
notice
and just ask Amy to move on to the
um
next screen please
this screen share shows the the
application site it's the area that's
outlined and then the site itself in
brown you can just see to the
um Southwest the railway line that's
referred to in the report was an
embankment that carries the railway line
and then you can see the primary one
system two drone fuel road that prints
this site
thank you Amy
this chair again its members will be
familiar and shows the application site
outlined in red the remainder of the
site
etched in blue which is angled or
controlled by the applicant and as
members can see that blue area comprises
the existing fleur de lis building and
Associated heart standing area with the
red area comprising the remainder of the
car former car park to the pub
thanks Amy
this is a depiction of the application
side chair the
plan of the site shows the entire fleur
de lis
site the building to the left of the
bottom left drawing showing the existing
Pub building which has consent next
adventure for conversion to Apartments
you can see there's the access road into
the site with the area to the left of
there being part of that permission for
the conversion to that element of the
site has an extant consent the area on
the right shows the proposed building
and that corresponds to the elevational
drawings at the top of the slide and
you'll be able to see the six number car
parking spaces that form the car parking
provision to the application site chair
just one other point to make reference
to on this slide in the report
references made to a culvert
and negotiations with regards to
ensuring that was kept clear with an
appropriate distance around it to allow
for potential future maintenance that is
the strip of land to the right hand side
of the building and you can see there's
lettering on it that depicts the line of
the Culvert and the three meter wide
distance either side of that to allow
for maintenance
thank you Amy
next three or four slides chair show the
site panning from this slide which looks
in a subtly direction towards unston and
then we'll unround to the north of this
slide shows the existing building the
fleur de lis Pub which is the white
building in the foreground with the
Cottages beyond that lying adjacent to
it the site itself comprises part of the
car park and if we just pan around to
the next slide please Amy
the shows the the car Park area the
access being pretty much in the center
of that area and as I've said on the
previous slides that will then afford
access to a car parking area to the left
of the access road that would serve the
converted Pub and lend the area on the
right which comprises the application
site before you this afternoon chair
where the building that's proposed and
the car parking behind it will be cited
and remember to be able to begin to see
the treed area that surrounds the site
in effect if you could see through the
trees at the back of this slide you
would make out the railway embankment
that I refer to at the start of the
presentation chair just go to the next
slide Amy please
this slide just pans further round and
so the building would be located in the
foreground of this shot with the parking
area behind and then again Amy if you
would
and this completes that now you're
looking north towards dronfield itself
thank you Amy
the next three slides I think chair are
taken from the position of the axis into
the site so this again is taken from
that point looking in a southerly
direction towards understood you can see
the existing Pub building the white
building in the foreground if you can go
to the next one Amy please
this slide shows the property that lies
directly opposite the site
and then again Amy if you could just
then finally chair this is a shot from
the site access point in the northly
direction towards dronfield
that completes the the presentation in
my comments an introduction to this
application share thank you
foreign
they will each have three minutes to get
over their points they will be informed
with 30 seconds remain as members you
can ask them to clarify any matters that
have been raised but remember your
questions should only relate to the
points in which they've already made
if the technology fails us we have asked
them to send us in advance a written
statement of their comments and these
have been included in the late comments
report
I would now like to ask this speaker
he was speaking to objects on this
application can you confirm that this is
your name and that you understand the
process let's count for Alex Dane
I'm afraid Alex
do you apologize councilor Dale is here
um
thank you
are we ready to start the timer
and you'll have three minutes cancel a
day
okay
thank you uh chair uh for the
opportunity to speak um as the report
makes clear I've called in the
application so the committee can
consider the implications of the
proposed development on the green belt
on parking and on flooding issues in
this location
um it's worth making clear though at the
outset that it was several months ago
that I called this application in and
it's fair to say that things have moved
on a bit since then and particularly
Amendments have been made particularly
in response to the uh the concerns of
the flooding Authority which may change
the position
um slightly to to the time at which I I
called the application in
um as the report States the proposed
location uh of the four uh two bed Flats
is just outside of the settlement
development limit and is therefore
within the green belt the report
highlights that the site is the former
car park of the fleur-de-lis Pub and
could therefore be considered previously
developed land and given that national
and local planning policy also permits
development of previously used land in
the green belt where it's contributing
to meeting an affordable housing need
and is not causing significant harm to
the openness of the green belt and I can
appreciate that some committee members
may be minded to find the proposal to be
acceptable uh in terms of the flood uh
the flood risk and the impact on the
pre-existing flooding issues of this
location again at the time I called the
application in the County Council uh as
lead uh flooding authorities objected on
the grounds that the proposed building
would not provide the three meter
distance they're required to access the
Bulba at the top end of the site and
this was the primary cause of the
repeated flooding the Dunstan experience
between September and November last year
and I know that the scheme has been
redesigned sufficiently to provide that
three meter access and sufficiently so
that the flooding Authority has
withdrawn its objection and once again I
appreciate it this mainly the committee
to feel that the development development
is more acceptable than it perhaps was a
few months ago I do take issue however
with paragraph 7.33 of the report which
suggests that the applicant could not be
held accountable for any impact on
flooding issues in the area I think it's
fair to say that should the development
Works interrupt or disturb the call but
and I believe it should be made clear to
the applicant that there is a there is a
responsibility there to remedy any
issues
um and as the call that sorry as the
call that partly passes under the land
of the of the of the applicant
um I understand there may be a
responsibility for remedying in future
blockages that occur and Clarity should
be sought from the uh for the authority
on this matter
um just turning quickly to the issue of
parking which I would say is my chief
concern
um the total proposed parking for both
the Redevelopment of the pub site and
the and this this proposed development
is only 15 spaces we know that there are
parking issues in unston in in roads
such as Church Street and I feel very
strongly that the parking is is
completely insufficient to deal with the
demands uh that these two developments
are likely to have it's three minutes
okay thank you Chad
thank you councilor down have any
members got any questions about the
points in which the speakers made their
presentation
that has no for Market sequence people
on the screen
um
I can't see anyone indicating chair
oh sorry councilor Hall
yeah I just wanted to ask uh councilor
Dale about the flooding issues I know
there's been quite a few uh issues
recently well over the last few years
and uh uh adding uh property there in a
location where it is a the prime
location for the flooding does he feel
that the flood issues have been
rectified sufficiently
um before we're planning uh
granted to to limit any problems with
any future development there please
so thank you thank you councilman Hall
um I would say that the the uh the
flooding issues at that location are
better understood uh than they were
before so there were three instances of
flooding uh between September and
November there last year and effectively
the the primary causes I see it is that
the fields behind the railway behind
this site almost acts as a funnel and
all of the water surface water comes
down through a call that goes underneath
the railway embankment and it comes out
at the top end of that Pub car park
where there's sort of an open mouth that
then takes that water down a culvert
that's quite deep it's quite deep under
under land uh and it's quite a wide call
that then passes down that sort of line
that's on the proposed site under the
main road
um under the property of the of the
landowner opposite and down out towards
the river and that call that was blocked
on a few in a few places
um during the the that period flooding
last year which is which was the reason
why the water was coming out from the
railway embankment rather than going
into the mouth of the call that beneath
and traveling down to the river
underground it was just coming out over
the top of the pub car park
um and and then filling up the road in
front so that the whole of the road in
front there was uh was completely
um saturated as you know and was very
difficult to pass it even resulted in
the road being closed at one occasion
um the as I say the call that is better
known now I think the between Yorkshire
water and the county Authority there was
a a bit of a degree of not being aware
that it was there because I believe it's
quite an old piece of of apparatus that
wasn't on recent flooding Maps so the
fact that they are aware of it now is uh
is is is a good sign
um but I I would say that it shouldn't
become blocked again if it isn't
maintained properly it wouldn't take
long for that area to flood again seeing
you know seeing how quickly it happened
in the previous instances when we had
flash periods of rainfall there
the other thing I would say is that the
building is very close to the to the
road Frontage there and if that area is
flooded then uh in terms of the design
features I would I would
um consider that they need to be careful
to ensure that water doesn't Ingress
into that building should there be
another instance of flooding like that
again
thank you Council Armitage
thank you chair uh it's really to do uh
with the flooding uh bearing in mind
that the flood Authority are re-uh
redefined in a lot of these things uh do
you think in real the fact that we're
having uh what can be said as uh a
different weather patterns that we're
having these days do you think that this
even if it's cool that is cleaned out
and bearing in mind that's going to be
an awful lot of hard uh uh tarmac and
the car park which will go straight into
and onto the road do you feel that the
the provision that's there at the moment
is sufficient to take these flash floods
which we seem to be getting more and
more as we have today
uh a very difficult question
um I would say that the call that was a
primary cause of the flooding uh as I
understand it from the last occasion
um in terms of the certain impact on
surface water uh flooding it's difficult
to establish whether a building on that
site it is currently a car park so it's
non-permeable anyway so a building on
that site it's difficult to say whether
it would contribute more uh to surface
water uh sort of or lack of permeability
there on that side
um but
it's very difficult to answer but I
would say that we I think particularly
the residents who have experienced
flooding in unston over the past few
months before Christmas uh particularly
concerned about about how this might
impact on I appreciate the flood
Authority have
um satisfied themselves and I'm pleased
to see that the development has been
moved to accommodate that three meter
strip uh but I
I particularly was concerned about
paragraph 7.33 because it almost
suggests that the developer should have
no sort of consideration or
responsibility of these issues and I
really do think that they should I'm not
saying that it's a it's a a blocker a
completely to any development on this
site
um it's uh it's uh it's just a
consideration that needs to be very
carefully thought through
but there's still uh would you agree
that there's still a risk there
yeah I would say so if we experience the
sort of rainfall that we had in November
and if it's not cleaned regularly enough
I understand that that call that was uh
several years ago 10 to 15 years ago the
authorities were aware of that Culvert
and cleaning it and for some reason uh
stopped uh and it became it got
forgotten about and so there's always a
risk that something is old and as deep
as that could be forgotten about and and
the problems could reoccur yeah
thank you
does anybody else also Council
photography
you need to put your microphone on
because
you okay yes that's fine thank you just
a small Point
um I do drive past this uh area uh not
regularly but now and again and behind
this development is a railway line
and this Railway line is is hired up on
a bank immediately behind uh that this
uh where where are supposed to be
building these these houses uh has
anyone approached British whale or
anyone to do with them to make sure that
the safety of the bank behind
is is is is okay uh because it is
immediately behind where these houses
are going to be built
just just a point
I don't want anyone can say anything on
this at all
no because obviously nobody does know
the safety of the bank then
I I certainly don't know can you can you
say anything Alex please I I don't know
councilman could be whether Network rail
have been consulted or uh or whether
they've taken a view on this to be
honest
um there are there are a number of it's
fair to say there are a number of houses
and that are reasonably close to the uh
to the railway embankment and obviously
if they haven't been uh issues there but
I I I I couldn't say I'm not I'm not I'm
not aware of those issues to know I just
thought I'd raise the point that was all
thank you chair
thank you anybody else
um councilman box
thank you chair
um councilor Dale you made reference to
the parking or in your opinion the lack
of parking that you think in in terms of
numbers for the for the intended
provision and I kind of I'm leaning
towards agreeing with you there
um if there is a an overspill I'm not
familiar with the main road that runs
outside the pub if there is an overspill
where do you think that over spill will
go and will that in itself
create hazards on that road
thank you work cancel the Box
um yes the the
um mark from my perspective it there is
uh I mean if you think that there may be
couples living in some of the some of
these Flats so they ate one bed Flats at
the public they have a set of couples
each with their own car you know our
district is known for being quite raw or
most people our car uses it's fair to
say then straight away you're looking at
16 uh cars and the provision on the car
park is only 15 and you've also got this
new development that's been proposed
today to considering the impact from
there so I certainly feel like there
needs to be nearer 20 plus spaces on
this site and from my perspective
looking at the side there is some
additional space that's dedicated to
Landscaping so
um I wonder whether whether the
applicant could be asked to look again
at providing additional uh parking on
site um in terms of the the impact on
our neighboring roads the main road is
uh is prohibited uh for parking it's WL
aligned so they couldn't park on the
main road the most likely place is
Church Street so if you imagine the main
road uh runs back up towards unston
there's a left-hand turn to the Church
Street
um and it connects back up to Crow Lane
which is another left-hand turn so it's
almost a triangle with the main road
Church Street and Crow Lane uh Church
Street is a little cul-de-sac
um it's there's only a few sort of
Bungalows on there and one or two houses
um it's already got parking issues
particularly at
um Peak uh School drop-off and
collection times if there were more cars
there I can imagine it I already get
some complaints about parking on Church
Street and I would imagine it would get
um you know those would be exacerbated
if they were overspilled parking on
Church Street the only other locations
would be the car wash opposite where
there are occasionally parked cars but
obviously that's privately owned land so
I can't imagine that that
um you know they would be able to out
there without uh without sort of
upsetting the landowner there
thank you any more questions
no
thank you councilor down
um we have nobody to speak in support
and so and we've got with no agents
about no applicant
um so
uh thank you for your questions that
you've had
um now colleagues I'd like to take the
opportunity to put the questions to the
planning manager and all the officers
about the application
I would like to hear this part of our
proceedings focused on getting clarity
about any points that you're not sure of
once we have done this we can then have
our discussion about the application
based on all we've heard and read
that reason members I would be grateful
if you could not move any motions at
this stage let's wait until we've had
all I'll have the chance to make our
assessments again the same rules reply
please mute your mics unless you want to
speak
members of any questions for the
planning manager and officers those
wanted to ask please indicate
with councilor Pat and cliff
yes can I um come back to uh some
0.33 and it says darshakan to council
plug team don't objective proposal an
Australian strategy can be secure by a
condition
what strategy is that sir Adrian
just in terms of the the issue of the
the drainage chair members will note
that condition eight requires a scheme
for the creation of service and foul
water to the disposal of surface and
foul water to be submitted to the
council prior to the development
proceeding so an officer opinion chair
on that matter would be that that would
address any issues around surface water
per se the the point that um cancer Dale
made when he spoke to members chair
about the maintenance of the the
culverton and paragraph 733
um my view chair would be if members
were otherwise content with the scheme
but were concerned about future
maintenance of that covert I believe
that a note attached to any permission
would and bring the requirement to
maintain that I presume in consultation
in conjunction with the County Council
and the flood team I think that would
address that matter to chair
thank you thank you
excuse me Council off shipment
thank you chair
um I just wondered if you could clear
this up for me Adrian and tell me what
you thought about it on the one of the
objections that DCC did put in the
flooding team at DCC was that no part of
the proposed development shall be
constructed within three to eight meters
of any ordinary water course or and a
minimum
three meters for a culverted Watercourse
now the way I read that is that it's
three meters if there's no previous
flooding uh issues in that area and you
should be looking at actually eight
meters if in this instance there's
flooding right outside on the road next
to the proposed development
um how do you read that uh that DCC have
put in and um can you give us any
additional information on why DCC have
in their next updates not continued and
tried to enforce at that Etheridge is
kept
foreign
as far as I read it share the the issue
around the culvertis the matter with
regards to the three meter distance
which is why further to the scheme being
amended the flood team have said that
the three meter distance and the the
maintenance provision around the cord at
three meters is acceptable and that's
where we've taken their view on the
revised scheme and we've taken there
no objections to the scheme on its face
in regards to the scheme as designed
any further questions for the officers
right thank you for those questions
um thank you Adrian for answering those
that leads us to the final part of the
process
which is our discussion about what we
have heard what we think
about emotions oh sorry I've got
counselor full advantages
I just want to move on to the uh
following uh part that was all
after you've finished to propose a
motion
right well what uh we need Alan uh mayor
to um
please yeah absolutely yeah yeah and
this will only take a few moments uh
thank you
um please bear in mind members uh that
emotion must be moved and seconded
before of those is taken
if an amendment to emotion is moved and
seconded
that Amendment will be voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against officer recommendations
then the member who was moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving emotion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject office and
recommendations fails or in other words
this is not past
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion in
favor of the recommendations or on
another course of action
this will be need to approve by the
committee to another vote thank you
chair
thank you for that I'd now like to on
the floor to debate again could you
please refrain from moving any motions
until we've concluded our discussions
Council Mark Foster thank you chair
we've spoken a lot about flooding and I
understand the flooding issues down
there myself I know how much uh
inconvenience they've caused to many
residents both in dronfield and in
unston so we've spoken a lot about
flooding one of my main concerns about
this is we've already granted permission
down there for eight single bed flats
and that's within the settlement
development limit so that's on the
actual Pub itself now these additional
two-bed Flats the four additional two
bed flats are going to be in Greenbelt
now we're seeing that they are within
the actual car park and within the the
area but that's not the case they are
actually still within Greenbelt and for
me I don't feel now I'm not I'm not
heard anything yet that persuades me
that we shouldn't go outside our current
policy and policies I'm thinking of a
GS2 and H9 of the local Platinum which
we're giving an appropriate weight to as
we usually do here as a developing local
plan uh in that it's still
inappropriately relevant now even though
the officer said at the beginning that
it was only to Grant affordable housing
only
I still don't believe at this case at
this stage and I haven't heard anything
yet that says that we should be going
outside our policy and giving weight
because it is affordable housing because
that could open up every Green Belt uh
site in the whole of Northeast
Derbyshire for the reason of
um
uh to develop because it's uh for
affordable housing so as yet so I'd be
happy to hear anything from the from the
officers from Adrian or anyone else on
their their thoughts on that matter
Armitage
uh thank you chair I I agree with
everything that uh councilor Foster has
said
um the other thing is uh there does seem
to be quite a lot of uh what shall I say
uh guessworkers regarding the uh the
drainage and the flooding aspect of that
site uh bearing in mind uh we're getting
more and more uh storms I mean if we
take today for example we have a
different weather patterns which uh no
one seems to be able to predict you know
one thing or another uh and the other
factor is the car parking provision
which is just an insufficient provision
for this site so that's my feeling on it
have made
you want to come in Adrian
yes chair um Council Foster raised the
issue about affordable housing I'll deal
with that first if I'm age yeah the the
application is for
um for flats that will be for affordable
housing which is why I said at the start
that it was important the reasons for
that will become clear it's important
that that's clarified in any decision to
Grant permission that it is for
affordable housing
and Casper is also
clear that you need to take into account
your development plan policies and
that's absolutely correct and they do
generally presume against new
residential development in green belts
but there are exceptions to that and one
of those would normally be for
affordable housing where you may
otherwise Grant exceptional permission
within the green belt for affordable
housing but I think most
importantly is to take into account the
most up-to-date policy which is that set
out in the mppf the national public
policy framework which is the the basis
of your emerging policies in the
emerging local planets currently at
inquiry and just to quote from the mppf
it set out in the report yeah just to
emphasize that
appropriate development in the green
belt so not inappropriate but
appropriately don't will be limited in
filling or the partial or complete
Redevelopment of previously developed
land whether redundant or in continuing
use
which would not cause substantial harm
to the openness of the green belt where
the development would reuse previously
developed Landing contribute to meeting
and identified affordable housing need
within the area of the local planning
Authority now first of all chair members
will note that the comments of the
housing officer is that there is across
the district
the need for affordable housing and
she's also identified that there is a
particularly Dean honest and the key
issue I think the members will need to
assess chair is that you may Grant
permission for affordable housing in the
green belt that would be compliant with
policy but the issue is that it
shouldn't cause substantial harm to the
openness of The Green Mile so a slightly
different test than the normal not that
it wouldn't cause harm to the openness
of the green melt but substantial harm
so members need this afternoon in terms
of that green belt consider our Asian
share to assess whether
develop and developed terms would cause
substantial harm to openness so that's
the the issue I think that um the
committee will need to address this
afternoon officers set out that in our
opinion substantial harm wouldn't be
caused to the openness of the agreement
that would be a matter for the decision
maker either committee chair
just moving on to the two additional
points that canister Armitage made share
firstly the issue of drainage and cancer
Dale and members have had some
discussion about that already but I
think from a from an officer point of
view it's important to remember that the
site is currently tarmac so there will
be run off from the site should it rain
whether it be in normal events or
extraordinary events or other rain
rainfall events whatever they may be and
that the provision of
a building on that site shouldn't affect
that current situation so there is an
existing situation and I'm aware of
myself of flooding that take that's
taking place on the the honest to
dronfield road but we development of the
site in that form shouldn't make that
any worse and indeed with the
appropriately worded conditions
um it's the site should address its own
surface water runoff requirements and
implications satisfactorily without
adding to the burden so from an officer
point of view again bearing in mind the
comments the lead flood Authority
providing that the culverts properly
maintained and whether that be by the
applicant or the County Council as lead
flood Authority the developed in officer
opinion shouldn't exacerbate the
existing situation
and finally just on the car parking
issue chair members will need to take
into account the impact of the scheme on
on highway safety and all that entails
and provision of parking within the site
may be an element of that the scheme has
been designed chair in accordance with
you
hi members can I suggest we just have a
five minute
um five minute break while we address
that issue
I don't know if you can hear but I'll be
along in a second but a five minute
break is that our members comfortable
with that yeah sure
okay just five minutes thanks
foreign
yeah ready when you are sure all right
thank you very much sorry about that I
just hung on councilor uh councilor Hall
and councilor Foster and not yet our
councilor Foster's back councilor Hall
[Music]
why don't you just give him another
miniature
yeah well we'll wait in a couple more
minutes for people to come back Adrian
I'm sorry to say we missed what you were
saying uh in relation to council
armitage's um
questions so if you could start back
from where
platforms please that would be grateful
for in the chamber
you're my very best chair to recall what
I said
thank you
councilor Hall's now back in
okay if we can start again then please
chair that you you heard everything that
that I'd said about the affordable
housing and the issue in relation to to
Greenbelt yes you've just started to
talk about Council armitage's questions
when we lost you
there was two issues that cash geometry
should specifically raised chair that
first is in relation to drainage in
seconds car parking I'll take drainage
first
um hopefully this is what I said
the
issue about drainage is
um
one that you heard quite a bit about
from accounts per day on then discussion
by other members and from an opposite
point of view noting that the site is
currently tarmac officers would take the
view that there's significant runoff
from that surface and in any rain event
whether that be exceptional or ordinary
therefore the construction of a building
on the site shouldn't exacerbate the
runoff or the runoff rate from the site
onto adjoining land and indeed and we
mentioned earlier on about condition
eight of the recommendation that makes
provision or should make provision for
an appropriate surface water and fire
water Disposal system that may actually
um make the situation better but it
certainly shouldn't lead to a worsting
of the situation and then the addition
of a note to ensure that the Culvert
that runs along the north Northwestern
edge of the site is sorry a note to
ensure that the owner's responsibility
in relation to the call but being
attached to any permission again share
should mean that drainage situation
affected by this development shouldn't
be made any worse at least that would be
an officer opinion based on the advice
that we've received from the lead flood
Authority
just finally cherished just going to go
on to the issue about car parking and
the design of the scheme
both this and the previously approved
conversion are based on the standard set
out in the development plan which
require in relation to single bread
properties one space per unit and those
in the
existing Pub building would be one bed
units and then for two bedroom units 1.5
spaces per unit and that is how this
scheme has been devised so the four
units and the six spaces would be in
accordance with that
ultimately chair members will need to
assess whether they believe that level
of car parking the level activity to and
from the site would be accept when
highway safety terms and where the
particularly in relation to parking that
would have an impact adverse or
otherwise on highway safety just on the
highway safety issue chair members will
note that the higher authority have said
that the access itself is acceptable and
therefore and bear in mind that advice
members will need to take a view and
what's been discussed in relation to the
use of the site and whether the
provision of the space is the 15 spaces
to serve all the units would have an
impact on highway safety and again just
to remind members share the test in the
mppf is that development should only be
prevented or refused on Highway grounds
if there will be an unacceptable impact
on highway safety or and this is less
relevant in this case but or the
residual cumulative impacts on the road
Network would be severe so that would be
the test in this case these chambered
officer's recommendation is based on the
standards that are set out in the
current development plan those are the
ones that um the applicant has worked
and that's on the basis of That's the
basis of our report is written on those
thank you Andrew can I bring in Council
on our message please
thank you chair uh it's just to pick up
on what's Adrians said about the uh
the surface water now I'll take it we're
going to have a new car park so we've
got a larger area of an Imperial uh
nature and that in my mind will create
more surface water than there is already
uh as it is at the moment uh the water
will go will permeate slowly uh through
the undergrowth and one thing in another
and uh councilor Shipman brought up the
fact of the distance between the Culvert
uh and the development uh quote in uh
what was eight meters uh so I'm not
happy about that and the other thing was
which councilor Huckabee mentioned was
the uh stability of the Railway
embankment bearing in mind the accident
which happened with us caused by a slip
in Scotland uh only a few weeks ago and
as far of the car parking provision it's
you know so much uh 1.5 uh Vehicles well
I don't know anybody who goes around in
a 0.5 of a vehicle so it's all uh
guesswork in life uh idea and I still
maintain that the car parking provision
is far too small and they all will
follow uh will end up going on to the
other streets
that's just the point I wanted to make
just come back when it's convenient
chair please on a couple of those points
yes please
just just on the point of the existing
car park I don't know if Amy you're
you're able to bring up the
um the presentation again Chad but just
to remind members that the current site
is as far as I'm aware and hopefully
some of the photos may help but the
current site is hard surface so the
um just any of those that that would be
useful Amy thank you just um the
majority of the site certainly is is
hard surfaced so that it would be
incorrect to say that currently
rainwater permeates through a pervious
surface just to ask members to add into
account
um the issue about and the issues that
cancer Armitage raises in in terms of
the information that he has
I just asked members to
note that in taking the decision on the
application if they are binded to refuse
the application on technical matters so
highway safety and parking or flooding
that whilst there may not be convinced
by some of the evidence before them to
substantiate reasons for refusal on a
technical matter we would need to have
our own evidence to bring forward to
substantiate any such reason so whilst
feeling that the information before them
may be
um on convincing that maybe
justification for that but to justify
reasons for refusal on those grounds
otherwise and we would need your own
evidence to bring forward chair and just
finally on the issue about the
embankment the railway embankment I find
it difficult to to advise members on
that
um in terms of the safety of that
embankment potential slippages cancer
Armitage is made but I I would urge
members to operate caution in respect of
that that
um members would need to have specific
evidence and advice I believe to justify
um a decision being taken on the impact
of potential slippage of the Railway
embankment and whilst that may be an
issue the rail went backward is some
distance away from the site and I don't
see any evidence before members this
afternoon chair to suggest that the
development of this site in the form was
proposed would lead in its own right to
the destabilization of that in bank
that's obviously a very serious
consideration but I don't believe
there's evidence before members to to
show that as it stands chair thank you
thank you Edward can I bring in Council
of foster please
thank you chair uh and thank you Adrian
for that uh I do understand that we
don't have evidence in front of those
uh further Evidence where we could
possibly
express our concerns and
not give planning permission to this
development
for embankment flooding and possibly
parking because we don't have the the
evidence here but what I do think we can
do uh and I'd like to propose is that we
don't give planning permission
for this application and against
officers recommendations uh and that's
because it's inappropriate development
and it's in Greenbelt and it would
create substantial harm to openness
because that's down to members here
today to decide that the substantial
harm whether it be harm or substantial
harm I do believe it's substantial harm
and I also don't believe that those
special circumstances have been met
so I'd like to propose that
yeah
but so thank you for that Council
Armitage are you talking against
something else or is it just a second
yeah I'll second that
is just a major just to make a comment
on to councilor Foster's motion if I may
when whenever is appropriate yeah
um well I don't think everybody else
wanted to speak at the moment uh Adrians
of his life oh sorry counseling our
shipment indicated to speak
thank you chair um it saddens me
actually that the affordable housing
applications as we get into this Council
seem to be inappropriate or shoving
shoving the housing in you know what
essentially is a flooded area I do come
back to what DCC said about this Culver
and the the the distance it should be
from the Corvette because like I said
earlier if this is a a site that we
obviously know floods then we have to
take that evidence which we know floods
because it's evidence
um and use it in determining this
application I think that we should be
enforcing a larger distance between the
Culvert and the property itself
um putting a building on there Will
almost definitely
um add towards the flooding issues it's
a car park that's got that's got
vegetation all over it it will so that
will help mitigate the runoff onto the
road outside
um and I think we just need to use the
words that DCC have used themselves in
their original objection and actually
you know that they they've they're
saying that they they uh the distance
should between three and eight meters
from the Culvert
um this is the very minimum this is the
minimum and I don't think that us as a
planning Authority should be granting
um approval to this application and I I
do agree with uh councilor Foster and
Council armatures that we need to um
reject this
um and and use the reasons that I've
said under Council Foster said thank you
hello
Adrian would you like to come in yeah
just too just to um speak to council
Foster's motion if I'm a chair note
exactly what accounts the Foster's
saying he's saying that
um the applications aren't acceptable
and inappropriate development as the
development would cause substantial harm
to the green belt I just wanted to ask
councilor Foster if um that's by reason
of the building's size massing location
position any anything
um in terms of specifics that um if
members are minded to refuse the
application and he would like officers
to add to that
decision to refuse the application in
terms of the specificities as I said I
just wonder whether it's including the
building's location is exciting or
there's anything else yeah mainly
location Adrian because it's in the
green belt and that is green belt there
I understand to cover the other issue uh
uh about how much affordable housing we
need but we've already got just next
door there for that area we've got eight
separate dwellings there's already
planning permission given for except
that dwellings next door within those
development limits so this is this for
me is one step too far so for me I think
it's location
thank Adrian and then just the the other
point in relation to the comment that
counts the shipment then made chair and
again this is a matter for members to
take a view on and I know what the
debate in
um about with regards to the the Culvert
but just to remind members of the lead
flood Authority have on the back of the
redesign of the scheme and remove their
objects and so so again yeah just uh
comfortable with them motion that counts
the fastest put forward but I would ask
members to exercise some caution in
terms of adding a technical reason and
less there is justification why three
meters distance either side of the
Culvert is inappropriate and why a
greater distance would be needed to uh
to safeguard that Culvert in terms of
the issue of service water runoff and
flooding chair
thank you uh Council Shipman
yeah um just to tag on to what the
debate with cancer Foster the location's
Bud because it's from the the building
itself right up against the road so if
you're driving by the openness is not no
longer open anymore it looks like
there's a building right next to the
road and I think that should be used as
part of the argument in terms of the
culvert
DCC have not objected purely because
they have hit the minimum requirements
not because they are it's not they've
not mentioned anything else about it
it's just that if you look at the
conversation back and forth in the email
transaction they just say with the with
the
um updated plan they don't object to
this proposal they don't say well we now
in agreement with the fact that it's
three meters they've just hit a minimum
so DCC can't really object as long as a
minimum it's up towards as a planning
authority to take what rules they would
apply and why they apply them into our
decision making and I don't think that
given we know it's a flooding hot spot
we don't even know if DCC have seen the
previous stuff that's happened there but
given we now as a planning Authority
that is a flooding hot spot in unston
then I think we should actually apply
that to our decision making in this case
that's what I was such
yeah if I did I could just uh come in
with the fact that if you look at the
photograph uh from the road to the
actual site the height of the curb is
only maybe two inches I think uh and as
a result there will be runoff from the
road which will also go on to the site
and where that's going I just don't know
it'll it'll just exacerbate the
situation altogether
councilor Foster
thank you chair I take Council Shipman's
points entirely I really do uh I
understand perhaps more than anybody and
Sam become a resident of John Field and
it's just down the road from me I know
how difficult it is down down there and
then do understand my concern is what uh
Adrian said if we do reject this on any
sort of flooding grounds
uh we can't possibly justify them
without doing our own studying so I'd
like to perhaps include what uh
councilor shipment says about the
flooding but my concern is is if I put a
motion forward that includes the
flooding that we can't uh substantiate
that without doing our own studies down
there that's my concern I take a council
Shipman's Point entirely but my concern
is whether it stands at a later stage
thank you councilor Foster anybody else
wishing to speak
Council Shipman on the flooding issue
it's up to the developer to justify
where they feel they've met the flooding
issues it's not was to to to evidence
that it's up to the developer to appeal
if they feel that they have if they feel
their minimum meeting the minimum is the
solution to their issue it's up to them
to justify why meeting that free method
minimum we're saying that minimum what
I'm saying well I don't know if anyone
else agrees I'm saying that that minimum
should should not be three meters I
think in this develop this particular
application I think that figure should
be higher I think we should be asking
them to have a bigger limit than three
meters from like given the situation
there
thank you Council Shipman anybody else
wishing to speak
to sleep
you take the motion and just need to be
clear as officers chair and exactly what
what members
um are voting on whether it's the the
reason in respect to Greenbelt harm or
weather chair it's that reason and also
a reason that it would be framed
something along the lines of the
building would be located only three
images from the Corbett and this would
compromise the proper
surface water drainage chair just need
to be clear
um whether it's the one or the two
reasons and and finally chair if members
are minded to
um go with that motion and resolve to
refuse the application whether based on
those um the wording that I've discussed
with with cancer Foster and cancer
shipment whether the final wording of
them delegated to myself in consultation
with yourself chair
thank you Adrian
um we're at the point with listening to
everybody I'll I'll bring it back in a
minute councilman Foster
um we listen to everything that people
are about to say uh today and we know
what the officer's recommendations on
we've had a motion before and cancel the
Foster and Adrian's now seeking
clarification
yeah thank you chair I'm happy to
include uh Council Shipman's points as
described by Adrian and um I thank
councilor Shipman for that so on both
points as you've described
so I'll propose that motion
and checks out as basically the same
recommendation which is just being
rather the same motion which is just
being slightly sort of collaborated
sorry I couldn't hear what you said that
until Marie now this is essentially the
same motion
um which is the one which was seconded
with just some slight clarification
points
it's for myself it's the same motion I
put forward but including Council
shipment's points as described by Adrian
there if that's clear and as counselor
Armitage happy with that as the
secondary of the motion uh I thought we
maybe should uh include the car parking
provision that it's uh insufficient for
the development
I don't know what to
uh Council of us to things
um thanks counselor
I like the idea of including it because
I think it's an issue there as described
by councilor Dale and as we've discussed
here I do think parking is definitely an
issue as it do with flooding but we've
already been given
[Music]
um
I'll say a warning but uh you know an
explanation by the planning manager on
whether we can actually include these in
the reasons for refusal plan information
and that we must end up doing now that
these studies so that's my concern I'm
happy to include it but what I do want
to do is you know
put these things in without it we don't
have the evidence in front of us I've
got the same concerns because I know the
area I know the flooding and the parking
so if we could have more advice from
Adrian on that do these Stack Up
ultimately the decision on these matters
is is one for yourselves there's
planning committee the the issue around
that whenever
um in mind it is accounts to refuse an
application on technical grounds we
would normally rely on some technical
evidence that land would support and
substantiate that reason should it be
tested at appeal and the comments I've
made around
um service worker drainage would be the
same for for car parking members need to
take a view on whether they believe that
in this instance the provision of the
car parking as proposed would impact on
highway safety and whether that impact
would be unacceptable that needs to be a
planning judgment what I will
um reiterate to members is that the
scheme and the officer report is based
on the
guidelines set out in the development
plan That's the basis of our
recommendation and also noting that the
higher authority haven't objected per se
on that ground but ultimately it's it's
a matter for members to take a view on
whether
on their in their judgment the provision
of the car parking it in this instance
19 spaces for the 13 units whether that
is
um except sorry the 12 units whether
that's acceptable or not and if it's
unacceptable is that resulting in on
that acceptable impact on highway safety
that needs to be the Judgment what I
what I would say Jen it's ultimately a
matter for yourself and your colleagues
as members of the committee if you are
minded on the issue of car parking you
would need to phrase a reason for refuse
or something along the lines of the
insufficiency of car parking resulting
in
the
provision of parking on the highway or
elsewhere that would in its own right
then lead to an unacceptable impact on
highway safety and that would be the
Judgment members would need to make out
from an officer point of view I hear the
concerns that members have but I've not
heard anything that would necessarily
lead me to then
relate that to an unacceptable impact on
highway safety but members will need to
take a view on that chair
thank you can I bring in councilman
Armitage and then councilor Foster
uh I think
can you hear me all right yeah
right uh I think Adrian has sort of said
really uh the provision uh it's always
as I see see it uh rather unsafe to go
against highways but on this occasion I
feel that there'll be parking elsewhere
due to the insufficient amount of spaces
and uh and that will impede on highway
safety whether it's parking on the Main
Street which there is uh double yellow
line so I understand and
parking downside streets which people
won't really like but you know
I'll leave it with the Council of foster
if he thinks it's relevant
before I bring you back in Council
Foster could I bring Council Ridgeway in
case you've got a different
um point of view yeah I'm just asking
we're talking about all this parking on
the road and everything when it was a
pub didn't people park on the highway
the car park was full and what impact
did it have then
and cancel the Bridgeway Council Foster
would you like to come in yeah thank you
dear I'm happy to include both the
flooding elements as per councilor
Shipman and the Park Municipal Council
Armitage don't have any difficulty with
that I find I've heard enough myself
that 13 dwellings and nine spaces means
somebody will park on the road and it'll
make it more difficult there how it
affects uh the road that we haven't
discussed as much here
but I don't sound pedantic about this
but I'll go back to the point that
Adrian said you did stay earlier on we
don't have uh sufficient evidence here
you said unless I'm missing that you
said we don't have evidence here to be
able to refuse on these grounds now I'd
go with both councilor Shipman and
councilor Armitage with the flooding and
the parking for me I think there is
enough evidence but so if we can have
some clarity on that because I'm happy
to put those both those uh items in
Emotion
the refusal of planning permission
please first of all Chad just um sorry
if I've misled members here but um it is
only the 12 units there's eight in the
converted Fleur De Lis and then four
this proposed here chairs so just at
that point of clarification
the issue of the
um both the flooding and the
highways car parking issue they are
proper planning considerations and
they're proper members weigh those in
the in the balance and weigh the issues
around them and the decision maker is
the planning committee as I keep on
mentioning so it's for the decision
maker to take into account those issues
and consider whether there is evidence
to support them whether you wish to
refuse the application on those grounds
as well
just become difficult should the
decision be challenged on those grounds
as a council without the evidence
that behind us to put forward
substantive reasons to support them but
members are minded to to abuse the
application on those grounds then we
would
um on the basis of the information that
we have
um seek to substantiate those but we may
seek to leave some knowledge from local
members as to the existing situation why
perhaps in in that instance or in this
instance concerns about on-road or or
other parking off-site would be
detrimental one thing I I do think we
wouldn't be able to substantiate is
um that neighbors wear cars may be
displaced to members of the public who
may live on those roads may not be
pleased with that situation that
wouldn't be something that we could that
wouldn't be a plan ingredient wouldn't
be able to be taken into account
yeah uh so it's like I put a proposal
forward that we include those two extra
items one the green belt the substant
sanction on how we've discussed already
what councilor Shipman uh said about the
the flooding and also adding the parking
from Council Armitage if we could put
those three together please and I'd like
to propose that and uh
yeah
right so as as a motion has changed from
the original motion have we got a second
councilman said she's second in it yes
thank you just just finally Chad don't
mean to prolong the debate but um if
members are minded to refuse the
application on those three grounds if
that the final wording could be
delegated to myself in consultation with
yourself chair please yeah I was just
going to say that so let's wrap out
tonight thank you very much okay so just
to be clear members this is an amendment
to the original motion
um
the original motion was
um sort of a version of this but wasn't
quite as extensive are you now actually
sort of moving a completely different
motion which was an amendment to the
original notion
right so the original motion was just
really about the green belt and
everything that we've only gone started
since the the uh the flooding and the
car parking yeah so the second motion is
the one that we will take first
as as long as what we're voting on
everybody's for me as long as sorry to
jump in there but as long as we're clear
that we're all brought in to refuse
planning permission on those three
reasons however you want to word it with
amendments or not but I'm happy to take
a new motion for all three reasons we're
all clear proposed seconded and we wrote
on it approach would just simply be that
this is the original motion which is now
being clarified with these additional
points if Council and Armitage as the
seconder is happy with that point
all right so um and as Adrian says if
you work with Adrian about getting the
correct wording around
the motion
moving forward that's okay
the motion then is to refuse planning
permission contrary to offer to
recommendations essentially on the
reasons actually discussed because it's
um location in the green belt the
potential harm to openness and then with
the actual references to the flooding
issues and parking also actually
included in the final wording to be
determined by the planning manager in
consultation with yourself is that the
essence of it
yes right thank you again you come
toward that Adrian
yeah
just just in terms of the car park it
would be the impact of the car parking
then on highway safety so it would work
that word that is part of the the reason
so the impact of of
um yeah the lack of car parking great
news subsequent impact on highway safety
thank you
um so I'll now move to the vote uh as I
explained earlier we'll do this through
a roll call
okay
yes thank you chair so I'll read out
everyone's names if you can just switch
on your microphone and clearly indicate
whether you're for or against or
abstaining so counselor ant cliff
councilor Armitage
four
councilor Barry against
councilor Cooper
against
councilor Foster four
hats for Hall
four
cats the hearts one against
councilor Huckabee
counselor could be your muted
against
councilor Potts
for
councilor Powell oh
Castle Ridgeway
against
cancer Rouse against
and councilor Shipman
all right verse the court to inform us
just in terms of that of all members
voted though was anyone abstaining
okay
you'd like to give us the outcome
I make that seven votes four chair
and six votes against Alan can you
confirm
sorry what were your numbers again
seven votes four and six eights against
right let's just go through this to be
on the safe side councilor and Cliff you
had voted as four four
councilor Armitage four four
councilor Barry was against councilor
Cooper was against Angela Foster was for
councilor Hall was four
councilor Hawthorne was against
councilor Huckabee was against
councilor Potts was four yeah councilor
Powell four councilor Shipman
four
councilor Stone
sorry councilor Ridgeway against against
uh carried chair
thank you just to be clear that's the
motion to refuse earning permission
against officer recommendations
is everybody happy with that
thank you
so thanks for that we've all shouldn't
spend
um moved and seconded and accepted by
the committee
okay so I'll move on to the left
application
already so the second application is uh
application LED stroke plenty stroke
00376 stroke TPO uh 156 honeymoon
Chesterfield S4 to 7ds application to
fell to Ash and one stickable covered by
the nedbc TPL number 57 brackets A1 at
156 Holly Moore Road Olive 27ds
once again in line with our normal
practice I'm going to ask the plumbing
officers to tell us about the late
comments any late comments reports that
have been produced and for the planning
manager to give a brief presentation
showing any photos and plans of the site
the meeting facilitator will share the
presentations on screen and this means
that I might find it difficult to see
everybody so do bear with
FR will allow officers to complete their
presentation
and ask members to reserve any points of
order or questions about the process
Until the End there'll be plenty of time
for you to ask questions later on
uh Adrian would you like to start the
presentation please yes thank you chair
first of all that there is no late
updates on on this item chair and then
thank you to to Amy if you just to move
on please as um you've said chair the
the application is to fell three trees
these are the red dots on the screen
before members generally comprise two
ash trees and one sycamore tree they do
occupy a site just one side of an
existing stream come Culvert and the
applicant states that two of the trees
are suffering significantly from
um Ash dieback and the other tree
because of the proximity of the
water course it's having a destabilizing
effect on the root systems of the tree
chair
just go on to the next slide please
maybe
now the three dots chair do identify the
trees and within the area TPO members
will see on the screen to the above the
the site and I think it is to the north
to the north of the site across the
other side of the Culvert there was
previously a large garden that Garden
has plenty of consent for a dwelling
that's currently being constructed and
it's part is a result of the um dwelling
there and the concern about the health
and safety of the the trees that the
application has been made to the council
chair the applicant's own property is to
the south of the trees and it forms part
of quite significant Garden area that is
owned and maintained by the applicant
thank you Elaine
foreign
to the others but is a closer ring shot
and it does identify chair just to the
south of the t2 T3 the existence of a
building and we see some photographs of
that in a second and finally Amy just
another plan this is the applicant's
plan identifying the three trees it's
it's not as good a quality at this in
this environment as the other plans that
officers have produced but it does show
the same thing and for sake of
completeness we've interchair you can go
into the photographs now yeah the first
ones are submitted by the the applicant
this is the
um tree number one and and we'll take
you know go to some photographs that
were taken last week and so I know that
the the trees generally should have been
in full
um Leaf then but you can see T1 which is
the not the tree that's overhanging the
highway but the tree next to that it is
suffering significant deterioration in
the crown with very limited Leaf cover
thanks Amy
and now moving on to tree two which is
the sycamore tree this is the base of
that tree and it does show the water
course to the left-hand side and you can
see how the water course is impacted on
the root system such that the applicant
is concerned about the potential impact
of the tree and its impact on the new
house it's being built just the other
side of the water course
thanks Amy
and this is also T2 chair that the
building on the left is the building
I've just referred to this is looking in
the other direction and you can see the
t2 there and how it's there's a leaned
towards the Watercourse thank you thanks
Amy sorry
and finally T3 this is the other ash
tree and you can see there that at the
base of the tree there is a significant
deterioration of the tree caused by
um certainly in the opinion of the
applicant and of officers you've
inspected the tree and significant
fungal infection
thanks Amy
then come on to some photographs now
which show um
uh that were taken last week that show
the trees in in slightly wider context
the T T's I think it's T3 oh no T1 sorry
is the tree in the center of the shark
which
um is under significant to duress at the
moment as you can see by the lack of
Leaf cover
I'm sailing
this is the the base of battery where
you can just begin to see just a cavity
at the bottom of that tree which again
in the opinion of officers is showing
signs of um Ash die back regressively
thanks Amy
and this shows um T2 and T3 that's the
building in the foreground and the new
house you can see behind the tree on the
right hand side is the ash tree and
again
um suffering significant duress at the
moment and then the sycamore tree in the
center which is the one that is
concerning in terms of its height and
location its potential impact on the new
dwelling thanks Amy
this is a wider shot saying showing the
group of trees the tree overhanging the
road is not one of those subjects the
application but the tree in the center
is the other two trees occupy a location
beyond the tree in good Leaf in the
middle ground and then just in front of
that you can see a small whole beam tree
which is referred to the officer report
which was replacement tree and granted
um previous to an application to remove
former trees that was a replacement tree
planted back then and it gives an
indication of how a new tree may have an
impact on the carriage of the area no
that's fine Amy thank you it's just a
wider shot simply chair thanks Amy and
then finally just some photographs taken
from the other side of the Watercourse
you can just see on the very left of the
photograph the new house then in the
center ground through the trees the
building that's on the applicant side of
the Watercourse and there's the water
course and those are the two trees just
on the left hand side of the the
photograph which are the two trees
subject of the application
thanks Amy
and just a slightly different shot of
that and again Amy please
and then slightly wider shot showing the
group of trees and one tree in the
center right that's
um subject to the application the other
two trees just behind the coniferous
tree that you can see there and finally
Amy please
that's just a shot hanging around
towards the road and you can see
um the T1 which is the center of that
shot with the limited Leaf cover thank
you chair
actually
I'm not going to invite the speakers to
speak as the clock has explained they
will each have three minutes to get over
their points they will be informed when
30 seconds remain as members you can ask
them to clarify any matters that have
been raised but remember your questions
should only relate to the points which
they have already made
as you know we have also asked them to
send those in advance written statement
of their comments or if the technology
fails on us
these have been included in the late
comments report back
and I think we have four objectives to
speak and we'll take you enough in the
alphabetical order I don't know if you
could cry for for me Alan I think one
lady may have actually left the meeting
yes that's right uh Tracy kitchen's
unable to now attend
um so I'll be reading her speech out for
her and Fiona mukflow um could have um
I.T difficulties
um so in the event that she is unable to
log on I'll actually read her speech out
as well so the first person that you'd
have is Vanessa de freche
thank you Vanessa would you like to
start
okay now
yes please yes thank you
um I've lived across the road from 156
nearly 16 years and the reason I'm
appearing today is because I just really
looked the trees
I've been drawn out at night time to
listen to the owls in them and I enjoy
seeing the bird life in them in the
daytime the ash trees obviously are very
important because of the die back there
are perfect habitat for a number of
species of wildlife they sustain the
insects and the bird life now I'm going
to mention this because my sons are
qualified and experienced the
boraculturist in Sheffield and I'm only
mentioning it because I'd like to
appreciate that I do understand the need
for tree removal and work on trees in
the correct circumstances
and I also value the TPO process because
it protects the trees that are so
important to the village and in fact I
was really upset when two trees with
these tpos were removed earlier in the
year
um that's T9 and T10 that aren't
mentioned on the plan
um there to facilitate the grounds of
the new building next door to 156 and no
one was aware of these being removed or
notified at the time so because I didn't
have chance then and I know I've got
chance now to say something
um going back to the trees the seeds
from the ash trees feed the bull finches
and other birds using use the trees for
nesting we've got Beatles caterpillars
and moths that feed on the leaves and
we've got a population of bats around
here and they surely feed off the
insects I just think it would be a
sensible decision to find a way to
manage them rather than remove them
the building next door to 156 has
submitted this application with
supporting evidence from a tree surgeon
that's Mr Alex Owen
now the report submitted doesn't give a
detailed structural assessment
and it even suggests the removal of the
trees with Ash die back but this isn't
really contrary to the latest government
guidelines on ash die back found on the
government website now for your
information that's
forestresearch.gov dot UK
the other trees as I said you said well
one is a Sycamore and the other ash tree
they don't have any good reason to be
removed because they're minor problems
commented on in the report and could be
managed either can be removed
limbs can be reduced so the existing
report really shows favor to the person
paying for the report and doesn't
mention the options of management
these trees are highly valued the
seriousness of three more trees being
removed especially following the
previous two that's five all in one area
it just causes a conflict and raises the
question should an industry stand a tree
inspection report be requested by a
qualified inspector before removal is
continued
um thank you absolutely thank you very
much has anybody got any questions
foreign
thank you very much for attending chair
just to let you know we now have Tracy
kitchen back in the meeting so she's
able to read her own statement right
thank you very much for that so it's uh
it's Tracy on next time please
um I just wanted to really add that um I
object to the application to follow
further Three Trees also
um protected under the tree
um tp057
um and this is because they're an
important part of the local landscape
and part of the protected group of trees
the importance of of keeping the rural
landscape in in the local area is set
out in the neighborhood plan
and as locals we feel that that should
be respected
the trees provide environmental and
Landscape benefit and should be retained
and maintained not filled
the falling of the two protected trees
in January this year is the subject of
some ongoing complaints with a large
group of local residents
um involving the local councilors and
also rmp for Northeast Derbyshire
so given the felling of the two trees in
January we all feel that it's crucial
the remaining trees in the same group
The retained and not fell
thank you thank you
any questions for this lady
no
okie dokie can I move to the third
person which is a Mr David on who
okay chair
thank you if you'd like to start yeah
thanks yeah
um further tonight we do rejection to
this application uh I'd like to
um emphasize
um that the purpose regarding the trees
for me wasn't truly clarified
um in replication it states that the
trees were to be removed for help and
safety reasons pedestrian uh Road users
and even occupy across the other side of
the Brook and I set all of that
information and I think it's credible
um but I do believe also there is
another side to this and it's not being
stated but as a purpose
um from the developers perspective but
the removal of these trees and previous
trees is to enhance the views from his
new development and increase natural
light
well I understand that and emphasize
with that but the problem is that if
we're removing tpos just to enhance uh
natural lighting and use I think that's
a sacrifice of of tpos uh that is not
necessary
um you know I'm very empathetic with
um the applicant because I know that
it's a challenge to manage trees of this
nature and you know I am the fairness
but I also understand that trees of this
nature need to be looked after and
managed and if it's issues of health and
safety in regards to the trees then you
know the riot approach this would be to
see if we can manage it first to make
sure that the trees could be sustained
managed so that if any potential
movement or loss of branches from the
trees uh will not occur and managed to
sustain the Aesthetics that are required
as part of this process
so you know that's my kind of General
consideration
and the basis of where I come from and
all this is the decision is to make this
work uh decisions that need to be made
must be carried out with good quality
information and as I've gone through the
application and I've been through all
the documents relating to this I cannot
honestly say that I've seen any credible
data providing me information about the
health of these trees or I can identify
is qualitative statements from officers
uh from Specialists saying that the
trees are in poor condition but there's
no scope no methodology no structure to
the way that these scenes have been
carried out for seconds
did give an assessment of the trees to
my mind it wasn't good enough but he did
give assessment what was analytics from
an officers recommendation report was
one of the trees should be filled but it
didn't say the other two trees should so
I think careful consideration should be
given to the confidence of that
particular report face that there are
some emissions to it as I said thank you
very much for the opportunity to speak
thank you three minutes thank you Mr
pool any questions for this before
no and I'll move on to the next speaker
who is Fiona Maxwell
I don't believe it's here that's not the
case Amy
no she hasn't joined the meeting
report them please I certainly will chat
I live in holy more side and submitted a
12-page objective
Focus
Alan we can't hear you okay experience
sorry
about any better
that's better thank you
I'll start again uh I live in holy Moore
side
oh and you've moved away again sorry we
can't hear you right the three you step
back we can't hear you no Time Lucky
yeah uh I live in holy more side and
submitted the 12 Pages
no sorry Alan we still can't hear you
and you want me to read it it might be
better
okay
I live in holy moorside and submitted a
12-page letter of objection in Mr Mr
coates's application to fail protected
trees on his property I won't go into
detail again but just want to point out
to the planning committee the importance
to residents of retaining these
protected trees they grow alongside the
local Brook enhance that area which is
by the main road through the village and
benefit local wildlife retaining these
trees is even more important now that
the owner of the applicant's agent has
delivered the neighboring property and
failed protected trees along the
boundary feeling any more protected
trees would further alter the landscape
of that area to the detriment of
Wildlife and local residents and for
this development took place the
applicant never alleged the trees were
dangerous despite pedestrians walking
under them every day
in the current climate when local
authorities are fully aware of
environmental issues they should
encourage landowners to maintain
protected trees not fail them the
environmental value of established trees
over less mature Replacements is well
known
the fall knocked down the children from
the local schools stood on the main road
with their teachers campaigning on
environmental issues what message will
be sent to them if more protected trees
near their school which could easily be
retained or failed the only expert
evidence supporting the application is a
tree assessment report dated the 27th of
April 2020 from eco tree co-limited this
report recommends a felling of T1 it
doesn't recommend the felling of T2 or
T3 I don't believe the planning
committee should agree to the selling of
all three trees even the applicant
expert didn't State this was necessary
the trees could and should be retained
with proper maintenance this would
alleviate any Potential Threat from them
which the applicant alleges they now
pose I therefore object to this
application even though I expect it will
be approved despite the lack of expert
evidence to support this
thank you very much
anybody got any questions in
relationship
with this lady well does anybody got
anything they want to ask
no thank you we've got the agent who
wishes to speak it was a Mr Dean
Trowbridge
thank you for the opportunity to speak
I'm Dean treybridge technical director
of Woodward homes era Atkins agent on
behalf
yeah as they assault in the office of
presentation the trees proposed to be
failed are in a poor state of help and
are nearing the end of their productive
life and then selling and replacing T1
T2 and T3 are in line with both national
and local planning policies due to the
recording state of the tree and the
applicant's willingness to repulks in
the trees at the next available
opportunity relevant policies are refer
to the committee reports I won't repeat
them out today it is pertinent to know
that removal of these trees were not
sought during the buying occupation for
the new dwelling adjacent to the
application boundary however should the
trees have been assessed individual
basis
rather than as a group removal of the
trees would have been sore
due to the danger they represented the
dwelling as were the two trees that were
removed earlier this year they were
included as part of the full application
for the single dwelling they weren't
done without a commission
whilst we agree that the group of trees
do offer a high volume in relation to
immunity trees get forward from a very
literally contribution to this and our
post lessons
[Music]
overall the immunity would be protected
and improved in the long term should an
approve will be given for replacing the
dying trees it is clear that all three
trees are Beyond any reasonable repairs
but could bring them up to an acceptable
standard and not negatively affect the
immunity multiple branches would need to
be removed along with major parts of the
troll which would more than likely kill
an already diseased true
as the amount of removal would leave a
wound with the potential to become
infected or investment
as the applicant explains the
application is not received any
objections from the cultural Department
in the comments of the trees are Hollow
contained that Ward within the canopy
and are suffering from Ash die back
cholera dieback has the potential to
spread through water splashes
potentially Place Another treatments
within the group in danger
throughout the application we have
discussed in detail how we can mitigate
the immunity to ask you the removal of
Industries this would be the interest of
the applicant and wood on are you aware
of building the adjacent dwelling to
retain a high value immunity space to
increase peripheral and privacy we are
aware that any development or removal of
habitat is a sensitive subject and as
such the trees would not be removed
until an estimated
replacement trees will be planted within
the next planting season and suited the
state as per British standards which
will help to ensure the continued public
Community value of the youth groups
increase 30 seconds given the
aforementioned preceded approach with a
holiday abroad we would welcome welcome
back recommendation
as well as the statute of statutory
conferences comments
in this instance to approve the
application allow my clients to secure
the long-term value in a manner that
benefits the site and why the borrower
without basic habitants and pedestrians
at risk thank you for your time I look
forward to answering any questions you
may have
thank you Mr Trowbridge I've got two
numbers and showing they wish to speak
the first one is Council of Ridgeway and
the second one councilor Armitage yeah
thank you for that um you mentioned that
um you've got a report that says that
all the trees are of poor health and
that they're coming to the end of their
life well not according to my
documentation it says that one of them
has only got exposed roots and the other
one has got a small cavity it just says
that one has been
um
uh
is is ideal for a failing so I don't
agree with your your um
assumption that all three trees need to
be knocked down
thank you
thank you chair it uh the question is
this uh when you put in for planning
permission in the first place and you
consider that they were taking there
were trees there with a TPO and did you
uh adhere to the root protection area
when you were actually building the uh
the the development
Mr Trowbridge would you like to respond
yeah I'm the first one I know that the
um report we submitted stated that only
one
tree should be filled but
um if you actually read the reports
clear that you're the two are Beyond and
kind of repair and we'll need removing
within the next six months anyway and
that's backed up by what's parks and
said and I think the office is report in
memory
and the blue protection area was a
planning condition to fence this off
which we did we didn't go in there we
didn't alter it at all so it's nothing
to do with the construction that happens
um next door and if the trees weren't
when they were assessed as part of that
application they're only assessed to the
group whereas if they're assessed
individually we would have thought that
when we would join that application as
well
okay thank you very much any more
questions Mr Troll Bridge
I haven't got any questions there well
right thank you very much Mr chairperson
thank you
yeah colleagues you'll have the
opportunity to question the planning
manager and any other officers about the
application
I'd like to keep this part of our
students focused on getting clarity
about any points that you are not sure
of once we've done this we can then have
a discussion about the application based
on all we've heard and read that reason
members I was grateful if you could not
move any motions at this stage let's
wait until we've heard everything and
have a full chance to make our
assessment again the same rules apply
please mute your mics unless you wish to
speak
thank you Adrian can I pass across to
you please
yeah happily uh take any questions but
just to
um advise members that in terms of the
the application we have taken the advice
of the council's own and arboricultural
team and they came within the the parks
section of the Council Street Scene team
and Kate Harris has advised that she
would have no objections to the remove
of the the trees on the basis of what
she's seen from a ground a survey but
just just in terms of the process that
members will need to go through chair
Members First of all need to assess what
an empty value of the three trees have
in terms of their their wider character
and how they provide some amenity to the
to the area bearing mind that part of an
area TPO so there are other trees in and
around them
you need to consider them whether the
proposal is Justified
whether there would be any loss or
damage if you can if you refused consent
for the fellowing of the trees or works
you do need to consider the development
plan issues and they're set out in the
officer report in terms of the local
plan and the wingworth
um sorry the holy Moore Side
neighborhood plan you've mention of that
in the representations to you you also
need to then take into account any
expertise or expert opinion that's been
offered and finally Channel though Jim
may be able to provide you better we've
lost connection yet again
um so if Alan if you can hear me if you
can arrange variety to come around I'd
be grateful and again just to take a
short break while we try and get this
rectified thank you in five minutes Joe
foreign
18 Council of Powell and councilor
Hartson who was now just arrived so it's
just councilor Powell
was also now arrived that's it
all right thank you
um I'm just trying to catch in my about
now those five minutes I think we were
with Adrian
um talking as an officer on the
application and carry on Adrian please
nothing the time doing it at my end she
had the the out outbreak seem to happen
when I'm the I'm the middle of saying
something so I apologize if it is I
don't know how far I got in terms of the
the steps that members will need to go
through in terms of in terms of the
application that I talked about
assessing the amenity value then and
justification for the proposal the loss
or damage if consent were to be refused
and taken into account the development
plan issues which is set out in the
report chair any expertise and expert
opinion that's been offered and also
chair I was just about to say that
whilst Jim may be better advised on this
and members also need to be aware that
in making the decision it must be
soundly based as if loss or damage
um is as a result of a refusal and there
is some potential for compensation to be
payable just in terms of the issues
chair and then happily take any
questions we have some sort the advice
that I believe I said of our colleagues
in the Council Street Scene team who
take the view that there is it is
appropriate to permit the refused look
sorry the um the approval for the
felling of the three trees and and
hopefully the photographs that were
shown earlier on share do show that
um two of the trees at least are in some
distress and in an officer opinion
certainly offer very limited amenity
value but to happily take any questions
share if that will help members
thank you Adrian anybody got a question
I've got councilor no Potts and
councilwinning Armitage and then the
counselor lost shipment
many thanks chair
um
I just wanted to ask that I've got a
number of the objectives of doubted the
Integrity of the report
um and are calling for an independent
report and I would personally consider
Council offices not Council offices but
the council are boring culturalist to be
an independent expert can I just
therefore clarify with the planning
manager that the person that it has made
these recommendations about future of
the trees is indeed qualified to do so
certainly chair it's our customer
practice to take the advice of our
street seeing colleagues who do
undertake advice and works on the
council's own tree stock and yes we do
believe that that is a well-founded
opinion that is based on the sound
knowledge of our border cultural matters
I hope that's clarification of the
councilor pops chair
thank you Council Armitage
yes uh thank you chair when this
application well the planet application
came in did you draw uh were the
conditions as to regarding uh the tpos
uh and were the uh route uh protection
areas uh were they mapped out and were
they policed uh did you check that they
were the right size
each other's two elements this first of
all and members clearly need to assess
the application
um before you that's for the felling of
the three trees and two
um seek to take account of the
shoes for the house to the north side of
the brook in my opinion Sherwood and
complicate the matter unnecessarily
having said that yet
um the comment that cancer Optics made
is in relation to the new house
committed to the north of the brook but
I can advise members is that that was
properly granted consent by the council
it's extant and as far as investigations
have shown it is being built in
accordance with those drawings chair and
in respect to the two trees that were
mentioned mentioned in representations
to members chair I can confirm that they
were otherwise protected trees but they
weren't removed without the proper
authorization the council as they were
shown on drawings that were submitted
and considered as part of the planning
application so just to be clear chair
the two trees that reference has been
made to were removed and properly and in
accordance with the appropriate
permissions
shipment
[Music]
thank you chair um I the
um forgive me I forgot his name Dean
Trowbridge the um for the person that
wants to trim the trees mentioned that
um they plan to replace them many years
time or whenever a suitable term is I
don't actually see on this application
where it mentions the replacement trees
is that uh missing from the application
or is that just
do you know Adrian and can clarify that
yes Joe it's a condition four of the
recommended
consent um sorry I must have missed that
so
so all three are going to be replaced on
this side that's right Jay yes that
would be the requirement of the
permissible granted that would be
required to play replace the three trees
with three of those heavy standard it's
specified in the condition which is and
Cancer Treatments perhaps a wheelchair
so I apologize if I'm telling him things
you're already married but they're quite
the significant size of tree okay now
that's fine thank you
questions
Jim field
for your lunch
so Adrian mentioned that I may be able
to assist if members were wanted any
information regarding uh uh compensation
so I don't know if that's something
members need would would require advice
on or
I think that'd be a good idea
I mean essentially if
um we um you decide not to give consent
and it is
um
and if following um your decision not to
give consent to any Works
um there's a damage caused by the trees
and it is subsequently found that we
should have given consent for the uh for
the works of the trees then uh
compensation may be payable by the
council to the injured party
uh so I mean that's the the basically
that's the situation regarding
compensation
thank you for that
uh um
Council Hall
um microphone yeah so Adrian a couple of
questions I was going to ask were uh
were the
um
uh that the expert in the report it says
that one should be fouled and not the
other two if the other two were the ones
with Ivy in then would it not be more
appropriate to get the IV cut back from
out of the trees uh maintain or manage
the trees and then uh and then see how
the bathroom then on because uh what we
hear about is there going to be any loss
yes of course there's going to be a loss
because it's going to be decades before
trees grow back to the standards that
they are or the the other thing I was
going to ask is where you say you put
two about planting uh three um
substantial trees I think is you may not
have said substantial sorry but got the
word enrolled but what what do you mean
by that would this be more than saplings
then could you explain that to me as
well please
um yes chair first of all
um members need to consider the
application before that's for the
felling of the three trees if you feel
that's inappropriate it would be my view
you could Grant consent for one or two
trees to be filled and for not for the
the third for example that would be one
option for you if you felt that
um tell me that three trees wasn't
appropriate in terms of the amenity
that's offered and you didn't consider
other matters overrode that so that
would be one option before you just in
terms of the the issue of The
Replacements I think the council Hall
mentioned the heavy standard I don't
have the definition in front of me chair
but heavy standard is is not a sapling
it's the work from sap things up through
standard to heavy standard and perhaps
even larger trees but it would be quite
a significant tree you wouldn't normally
seek to have a replacement tree planted
of two largest eyes because often the
smaller they're planted the better they
adapt to their surroundings or the
better they're growing the long term but
to have some element of immediate impact
you would normally go for something at
least of a standard size with a heavy
standard is higher than that I can get
the definition if members do require
that in terms of what exactly would be
replaced
um but hopefully that answers the two
questions that councilor Hall has got
and I've just managed to uh to find it
to share it I believe the heavy standard
is
up to roughly in approximately 16 to 18
centimeters in in girth so it's quite a
significant tree if that gives remember
somebody about eight inches
thank you any more questions for Adrian
okay if I can just um say one of the um
public speakers
don't go back again
and see you in the clerk one of the
public speakers has asked if they can
ask a question how advise I don't think
there's any provision for them to do so
but um I thought I'd raise it we
wouldn't know that because that's
another question at this point in
um
yes absolutely sure and the role of the
public speakers is
thank you so
um sorry about that but we'll move on
overcome so thank you Adrian for
answering those questions and that leads
us to the final part of the process
about discussion about what we've heard
what we think I'll move on again
foreign
[Music]
around there
we've heard about the rules in the
roundabouting so I'd now like to walk on
the floor for debate again you could
please refrain from moving and emotions
until we've included our discussions
so um
have we got any debates that want to go
on this one
Council Ridgeway
um yes I'm I'm horrified that this has
been brought to the committee actually
because
um I'm very passionate about keeping
trees and I think as a planning
committee we should be
um protecting the trees that have got
tpos on them and we should be managing
them not just allowing people to come in
who want to build houses and save their
outbuildings to chop trees Downs these
trees have been there far longer than
these buildings will be standing
sorry we're gone again
but with this let's see how we go this
time see what happens we've had a change
of cable so hopefully we should be all
right I think we were on the debate
about the trees is there anybody else
that wishes to talk on this debate
councilor Armitage
thank you chair uh I'd just like to
uh the tpos were meant to be put in for
uh uh you know protecting the amenity
values of trees and we've already had
it's been reported that two are being
failed and now we wanted to fail three
more
as I see it the main problem with these
trees uh is that they're spothered in
Ivory it's the correct management of
being put forward earlier these trees
will be in uh good condition all you
have to do is to cut the uh where the
eye is going up is to cut it through so
and leave a gap of about six inches so
it can't reform
uh there are also signs that the trees
have had uh barbed wire uh fastened
across and this is just just crass
ignorance on the p on the part of people
who own the trees
uh
as far as I can see there is one tree
which is suffering from Ash diebach the
others are
they should be okay uh but it's it's a
lack of maintenance on all the three
trees and surely uh if they're on TPL
they should be inspected from time to
time and people told to put them right
and it's like uh councilor Ridgeway as
as pointed out uh what was there first
the trees or the house uh the the
development and that's something that we
must take into consideration
I have uh incidentally I did a
university cover uh aspects of Forestry
I also managed uh 40 acres of commercial
Woodland uh planting thinning and doing
all the necessary work and I recently uh
went on a dark training course which
covered things like I shouldn't iPad so
I'm more than uh well I know basically
what I'm talking about still that's that
thank you councilwoman said anybody else
wishing to speak on this subject excuse
me just before that is Council Roger
holzbach is councilor Foster
yes okay yes thank you
right then I think we've heard everybody
wanted to talk on this
and so thank you very much for that
having heard and read everything today
in the office of recommendations before
us what is the view of the committee on
the application I'm now opening the
floor to emotion anybody wants to put a
motion forward
um
right there's no motions going forward
so I think we take the belt on the
Market there are two hands up chair s
councilman Ridgeway and Council on
Armitage
Council Ridgeway
yes I'd like to put in that we go
against officers recommendation to sell
the Three Trees I'm happy if the one
tree that has got the ash dieback needs
to come down then I propose that we go
ahead and chop that tree down but make
sure that a substantial tree is uh put
in its place and the others are kept and
maintained
message
hi uh I agree uh wholeheartedly with
what councilor Ridgeway says
right so your second Council Ridge yes
thank you very much
right that's been emotion moved it's
been seconded
and just Arrangement before you take the
vote please
yeah just in terms of the motion that's
character ridgeways put in Chan I'm
taking it that the tree that counts the
Ridgeway is is happy to the recording
has stopped
oh sorry I drink can I just interrupt
the moment I made the recording and
stopped are you aware
yes this meeting is being recorded
should be back on now
sorry
makes me more concerned share it's me
that's creating the uh the gremlings
rather than somebody else I mean the
only issue I just wanted clarification
on chair before
um you take the voters that the laundry
that Council Ridgeway is putting forward
as to be failed is the the T1 which is
the tree nearest to the road
and uh that's just singly allowing that
tree to be be filled without the felling
of the other two which would be
um Jim may be able to clarify this chair
but if that were what passed we would
need to be very specific in how the
decision notice was was worded and um I
can't see you Jim at the moment but um
it would be along the lines of issuing a
split notice which I
um Split Decision which I believe we can
do with trees but if there's any
clarification on that or necessity to uh
to uh to see members clarification that
we would need to uh deal with that as we
go along but that would be my suggestion
if then was reminded to accept the
recommendation to issue with split notes
allowing the felling of One Tree and
refusing the felling of the other two
yeah just before I bring Jim in can I
bring in Council of pots
yes chair I just wanted to um to ask the
proposal of of the of the motion
um
is it going to be enforceable
to make the tree owner maintain she
referred to maintenance of the two of
the trees is it technically going to be
possible to enforce that because if it's
not we could we could just end up in a
position where the trees are left
purposefully or otherwise until they
become unstable and then who knows what
happens
that gives me concern that you're saying
uh maintenance but if we haven't got the
powers to enforce that
um
I could see issues there
right
um
yeah I mean as far as I'm concerned if
it's a TPO it's covered by this Council
the Council of the people that have to
maintain it as as Council Armitage
referred to before these trees have got
a protection order on it should be down
to us
to be protect to be maintaining those
trees so when I say maintain them it is
down to us to maintain those trees
because they've got the protection order
on them
uh right can I um I was intending to
bring Council of fostering first before
you responded can I bring Council
fostering and then Adrian please
yeah I was going to speak on a different
point but on that last point I don't
think there's any way that the the
council I think the idea is where those
protection orders stop people chopping
them down I don't think the uh the
district council maintains those trees
those private trees on people's private
land I don't think that happens but I'm
sure officers will come in on that I've
got the same concern as uh councilor
Potts uh how can we enforce that people
manage the trees correctly that's the
concern of mine uh my only comments on
this
um I put quite a lot of weight on uh Jim
fieldson's comments that he put could
put the council open to compensation uh
if we make the wrong decision and these
do create
damage to someone's property or person
so that's a concern uh another one is
I'm happy to take uh the opinion of our
own experts our own workers on the trees
and
um
if their their view is as it is I'm
happy to take that
um
uh and as for replacing the trees you
have to be replaced by heavy standards
seven inch in diameter they are
substantial trees I'm happy that uh
we've still got trees there that will
again become healthy trees uh and
they'll be in the in the correct place
so that
um there's a there's a three comments
I'd like to make thank you I'm gonna
ring Adrian in please
just get a new um address the issue of
of Maintenance counselor Foster's
actually covered that primarily the the
the reason for the TPO is to give the
council um formal control over Works to
the trees but it doesn't pass
responsibility for maintaining the trees
from the owner to the council that still
rests with a site owner and just the
point that counts the pots made is is
the council doesn't actually have any
powers to require proper maintenance of
the tree all it can do is to
um control for what the better word
worked to the tree but all that
responsibility for good maintenance and
good good arboricultural activities rest
with the owner and just uh just on the
point that cares the Foster may just
certainly absolutely clear which I
apologize if I've misled members what
heavy standard is 12 to 14 centimeters
so just below six inches so I I don't
want to mislead members but that would
be the the replacement trees would be
I'm just under six interesting girls
which again is is still in my opinion a
significant tree
that's already
do you want to review your emotion or
and counselor Armitage you were second
in that would you like to no I'm
sticking to my motion entirely because I
just think it's it's you know I think we
can put a condition that we ask the um
owners to make maintain them these trees
should have been maintained and and I
think we we can ask them to maintain
them and I think you know to chop down
three trees unnecessarily is is
abhorrent and I think you know if we if
we allow this to happen then we may as
well allow every single tree on every
single planning to be chopped down
that's my view
yeah hi I've got one one concern
regarding the maintenance to what Jim
Fields and has said uh it's all right
I'm saying that if we go against
officers recommendation and don't allow
the owners to cut the two trees down I I
am in favor of what uh councilor
Ridgeway has said about one being felled
and keeping the others but we also need
to be minded that the owners need to
maintain the other trees it's all about
them saying well we're going to leave
the ivy to grow until it it kills the
trees off or whatever whether they would
say that or not but what occurs if the
owners of the trees do not maintain the
trees and do not cut the ivy down and
then it's something were to occur to the
tree could they then turn around and say
well it's the council's fault whereas
could we then turn around and say well
it's your fault but not maintain
where is the comeback with something
like that please either for Adrian or
Jim to answer if you don't mind please
yeah I'm here yeah so I just turning my
my mute off
um
I think I mean that's a very difficult
uh question to answer uh the if if it
came down to who's to blame for any
damage caused by the the trees uh a
court would look at
um what the condition of the tree was is
now and
um
whether the um whether the failure of
the council to Grant consent has led to
the um to the damage uh but it was also
it would also look at whether the
um the failure to maintain in the future
has has led to a a worsening of the tree
which has caused the damage
so I think it's it's not a um a question
that I can answer with any any degree of
certainty at this stage you'd have to
look at the um the actual condition of
the tree now and the the condition of
the tree as a result of the failure of
the maintenance in the future uh as a
whole in that
that
may may point to the council being
responsible or may point to the the
owner being responsible it is it's
impossible to stay at this stage
okay thank you that's what I wanted to
know that the council could then come
back and say in a year or two or five
years time and say you've not maintained
the trees so you have to take all some
of the responsibility I think the the
longer
um this this goes on and the uh the the
longer they fail to maintain that is
that is likely to be the council's
position when looking to defend its its
position if there is a compensation
claim
okay thank you thank you does anybody
else wants to speak Council pots sorry I
was just going to say can we move to
vote chair
well we've still got somebody else to uh
just think sorry counselor Parts Hall
uh yes chair
um I apologize I have to sign out and
sign back in so I've missed the motion
um I have no idea what's actually been
proposed so can we just have a repeat on
that please
essentially the motion at the moment is
um that permission be given for the uh
for knocking um well for cutting down
the uh tree which has been affected by
Ash dieback with the condition that a
substantial replacement tree we put in
its place
and that the second part of it is that
against offer recommended officer
recommendations the two other specified
trees may not be given permission to cut
that to be cut down is that the essence
of it
I think it is as far as I recall I've
just got one more speaker on this and
then we'll move to the vote uh counselor
Franklin
[Music]
can I just ask you Adrian if so we go
ahead with Council ridgeways about him
could we not play something there that
their owner is they're liable in a way
to
um look after those trees within a set
time and that it would be um looked at
to see that that work has been carried
out
now I'm not I don't believe that the
council has those powers to require
certain Works to be done all the
council's powers are that um that and
again Jim will correct if I'm wrong here
I'm sure chair but if there's any
willful damage to the tree then that
would be another matter I think in
contravention of the tree preservation
order but just to set a minimum I don't
believe that the council could
um properly say to an owner of a tree
otherwise protected that you will do
certain Works to venture its long-term
health and safety chair I don't believe
we have the powers to do that uh I would
con confirm that the application is
purely for the removal of three trees
and that is the decision that you need
to make you you you can't make a
decision to uh to make the uh the TPO
even more onerous than it currently is
so yes I agree with Adrian
[Music]
will come and be looking at this through
cost uh whether that's compensation or
not we don't look at any other plumbing
applications through cost so uh you know
I'd like to think that we were looking
at this on the actual applications
inventory falls down because it could be
completely the opposite Council Armitage
and then we're going to the verb thank
you
uh uh Adrian uh
uh didn't really clarify on the fact
that uh we could uh chop and change on
this and say uh uh uh cut one tree down
and leave the other I also understood
that when there was a uh when there was
uh an application it was the application
which is in front of us that we had to
consider uh without uh going and
chopping and change could uh Jim perhaps
uh clarify it
yeah so so the application is for
consent to remove Three Trees so you you
you can um either consent to all three
trees being
um been removed or uh one two or or not
none of the trees been removed so you
can
um that is they are the decisions that
are available to you
thank you right
um put in front of us and it's been
seconded
so can we go to the vote
um and that again will be done by roll
call
everybody else
yes again I'll read the names out if
people um counselors can clearly
indicate it's four against her
abstaining
um councilor ant cliff
and for this moment
Council Armitage for
councilor Barry
um
is that four sorry four yeah
councilor Cooper abstain
councilor Foster against
Council
ball
Chancellor hartshorn or
councilor Huckabee
cats for Huckabee no four four thank you
councilor Potts
I'm against
councilor Powell
you can't hear you Council Powell can
you put your microphone on please
thank you councilor Ridgeway
I'm for it
that's the Rouse
people
and councilor Shipman
for
with 10 votes for that motion's
character
thank you
just to be clear that motion there was
to allow uh or to agree with officer
recommendations in terms of putting down
the tree the protected tree affected by
Ash dieback but the other two trees
offers it against officer
recommendations uh permission has not
been granted to actually cut them down
about the essence
yeah okay
thank you for that members the Martian's
been approved by the committee
so we'll move on to the third
application are you
all alright to Carry On by a few what's
another decent break
before we go on to the next one the next
one alone
um Chad I've got to leave at four so I
I'll probably leave now before we get
involved in the next one
comments Council of Boston yeah is it
possible we could defer this and set
another date for this
because uh if we if we're missing one
member already and we're already ten to
four here if this is going to be we've
been three hours on two a tree and uh
a tree application and also uh the one
with the fleur de lis this looks a lot
lengthy and a lot more in depth and I
think he probably deserves a you know a
lot more looking at than people
now
I tend to agree with you but we do have
speakers here that have taken the time
to come out of work or whatever so I
think we need to give some due
consideration to it okay
okay can I asked Alan for advice on that
one please
the essence of it shared is that if
members wish to move a motion to defer
the item they could do so and if it was
seconded and then voted for then the
matter will be deferred but I think
you've made a a fair point that
obviously we do have other speakers here
from external bodies and members of the
community so it's really down to the
members as to whether they wish to press
on uh I don't know whether Adrian's got
any views in terms of the uh the
specifics of this
Carol all I would say as Alan said it's
it's a matter for members absolutely and
you do have I think there's there's
eight speakers
um down to speak with you and Alan can
perhaps confirm that and the applicants
have been looking for a decision on the
application for a while it um has been
put back and been caught up in the in
the covid-19 issues just asked members
to take that into account but ultimately
it's a matter for for you as members but
I don't think it will be a a
straightforward application that we
dealt with in a short space of time
makeup members that there's nine
speakers
right is there any chance that yourself
or maybe could speak to those speakers
to get their viewpoints so that we're
taking them into consideration before
deciding what to do
I'm not sure how practical that will be
at this late stage in terms of sort of
literally instantaneously and obviously
um
I mean
I mean we could try but I think actually
the essence of it is is do members feel
as if they want to continue this now I
mean there is the issue of sort of
obviously sort of you've got uh people
who have actually sort of wanted to come
um to this meeting today for it and
whatever do you think that Adrian's just
said
um I'm not sure
um in the circumstances yes we could ask
people but whether that just puts them
on the spot
sorry
yeah I I think we should continue at the
end of the day people have taken the
time out of work or whatever to come
here and if we've got enough members
even if one has uh has uh had to leave
the meeting if we've got enough members
to continue then we should do if uh so I
think we should do yes
thank you I'd actually go with that
point of view as well uh councilor
Shipman you what you were saying
something yeah I just wanted to agree
with cancer all at the end of the day we
we're you know our job is to see my
application it started at one I think
everyone understood that you know when
you've got big applications like this
it's not as simple as they're going to
be doing in two hours sometimes it takes
more detailed discussion to get to the
bottom and come out with a good decision
we've got eight what nine people here
waiting to to tell us what their
concerns are I think we'll just need to
crack on instead of wasting time talking
about whether we're talking on or not
councilor pops
foreign
just ask then what what you would like
me to do I I have to leave the meeting
at five o'clock do you want me to leave
now or do you want me to stay and be
involved and hope that we've come to a
vote by five o'clock uh can I just
actually interrupt that uh I mean
although there are nine speakers two of
them will not be present so uh one of
the Clarks will uh simply read out their
text so that actually reduces the number
a little bit
can you just clarify for us now that
what is the best way forward for Council
of pots to go should you stay into it
until five o'clock
or should she remove herself from it now
um
sorry I mean the difficulty is of course
is that um it may actually be finished
by 5 PM I mean there's no way of really
knowing then I've been all the
applications in the past which have been
quite significant uh which have actually
been done within half an hour three
quarters of an hour so at that point of
view there's no guarantee that this
won't go on behind past five o'clock but
there's no guarantee that it won't but
it won't you know be finished by 4 45.
in that okay it's down to the member in
that case then can we um put it to the
Belt that the meeting continues
um are set out in the agenda uh those in
favor can you put your hands on
is this in favor of continuing chair
sorry yeah in favor of continuing with
the major
can you see that Alan I'm gonna
we got one two three four five six seven
two in the council chamber Alan yeah
well I think there's a clear consensus
there I mean I'm viewing this as not so
much emotion but just really an
expression from members that they wish
to continue with the set agenda right
and it would appear to me sorry
councilor Foster
just to make it clear I wasn't proposing
that we're that we stopped the meeting
uh it was a suggestion out there for
people to discuss
yeah that's fine so we shall continue on
the the one thing that was put was
whether you wanted a break before going
to the next one but I take it people
just want to crack on
you know let's just crack on with it
okay thank you
so the third application
is
um LED stroke one eight stroke zero one
two seven eight stroke ol and it's
Cottage Farm Matlock Road Westington
it's a conversion of existing car sales
and storage buildings to create a farm
shop a garden center restaurant and Tea
Room direction of a holiday Lodge
complex with reception facilities
construction of a village hall and
formation of a new access and that's
classed as major development long
surrounding Cottage Farm Matlock Road
Westington
so just to confirm once again that in
line with our normal practice I'm going
to ask the planning officers to tell us
about the late comments reports that
they've been that have been produced for
the planning manager to give a brief
presentation showing any photos and
parts of the site the meeting
facilitator will share the presentations
on screen and this means I might not
seeing you so therefore I will allow for
the officers to complete their
presentation and ask members to reserve
any points of order or questions about
the process Until the End they'll
reflect there'll be plenty of time for
discussion
um later on
uh so
um Adrian would you like to start the
application yes sir thank you thank you
again if I can ask Amy for help in terms
of bringing up the presentation chat
just first of all that need to advise
members um of the significant late
representations that were emailed out
um yesterday in which you're accessed on
Modern call they include chair um a full
list of recommended conditions and also
share comments made by the applicant
who's unable to attend the meeting this
afternoon just in terms of the the
details here this has been an
application a long time in the in the
making as members will see it's got a
reference number back to the very end of
2018 and it's gone through a number of
iterations but as you've just outlined
the applications now application outline
except for the issue of access and it's
the conversion of a building to a
variety of uses the provision of a
holiday Lodge complex and for the
probation or privilege Hall and
Community shop so if you just ask Amy to
to move on to the first slide please
share it and as is customary the area
that's hatched is the application site I
set out on the report you can see the
other
elements of Westington to the East and
the southeast and the area and just
opposite the road wind stains green is
an area of recently constructed housing
the detached element of the site is the
opposed area for the Village Hall but
the rest of the site which we'll come to
in a second comprises the building to be
converted in the area for the lodge
development
thanks Amy the next slide chair is just
a depiction of that on red and blue
lines as members will be customary and
the red line the application site the
blue land which you can see there is of
the land and the applicant claims
control or ownership over
the next slide Amy please
back in the 2018-2019 chair the
applicant sought consent for this scheme
which as you'll see comprise as we go
through this will comprises a much
larger scale of development in this
instance sort of intent for housing a
large Hotel comes far complex but
following negotiations and discussions
with officers that scheme has been
paired back to the scheme that's going
to be on the next slide and which is the
one that members are being asked to
consider
and that is for the scheme now that
seeks consent for the conversion of the
building that's outlined with the letter
e there and that's to be converted into
the visitor reception for The Lodges
Farm shop and garden center sales area
Associated eating facilities and
combined with that in outline there's
the areas of parking then the area to
the southwest of the site which is now
purely for Lodge development
and as you can see the area for housing
that was on the originally submitted
scheme has been removed but just to be
clear chair the application is in
outline with only the matter of access
reserved but this is the indicative
layout that's proposed and should
consent be granted there is a condition
recommended that would require the
development of the site to be in
accordance in terms of the uses with
this indicative layout
just to finally chat and before we go
into the other slides the area a which
is at the south east corner of the site
that is the area where the Village Hall
would be located
um yes please Amy the the next slide
chair shows the new access point to the
north of the site now this um chairs
members will be aware and does show a
right turn harperage well actually the
highway Authority does no longer um
necessarily really quiet that level of
infrastructure and is happy to to accept
a modified access provision but it would
all be within the highway limits and the
conditions would allow the local
authority to gain control over the exact
detailing of the access point just one
point of reference Jared the center of
that slide there are some words that I
can't quite quite make out here but it's
got an arrow pointing towards it and
that shows the existing change from 40
miles an hour to 50 miles an hour and
that'll be important for when we get to
the photographs later on if I could ask
members to reference that and actually
note that the access is on the 40 mile
an hour side of that notional line
across the road
thanks Amy
the next slide is is another one similar
to that chair just showing how the the
access may be laid out and the next
slide Amy please
and just for a sake of completeness
chair I did say yesterday at the site
visit that I would include in the
presentation the extract from the
Westington neighborhood plan which
outlines the site
um part of the site which is shown there
in Red so the building within that red
area is the building that would be
converted as part of this scheme so
that's the area in the neighborhood plan
that does
um seek does
um point to permission being granted for
business or tourism related
Redevelopment so that's just for sake of
completeness jail that is referenced in
the report we're now going to a series
of photographs that um we saw much of
much of this yesterday on the site was
it share but this is a picture in the
next three slides are all of the
um field where The Lodges would be
located and they pan ran from South and
if you can keep going in Amy please and
round to the west and that shows the
area of Rising ground to the West
and then that's looking North
and the Hedge as we discussed on the
site was that yesterday is the limit of
The Lodges and beyond that would be the
play area and parking provision that
would be associated with The Lodges and
again we'll come back to that at the end
the the last photographs where we'll
look back towards that hedge and the
parking proposed parking area
thanks Amy
next group of slides are across the
other field that would be
um the form of the area where The Lodges
would be located and that is the
building that is shown on the
neighborhood plan plan and that would
that's part that those buildings
comprise part of that site which um
would allow um in terms of the plan
business and tourism related development
but the cartilage of those buildings is
drawn tightly around them and reflects
the the fencing that members can just
see there thanks Amy without panning
around to the the south of that same
field
and again Amy please
so the boundary of the site for The
Lodges would then be that hedge row
there
and now Amy please
moving back to the to the site um proper
the green buildings there that is the
building that would be retained and
converted and it's apron where the cars
are currently parked that would be the
parking area as shown on the indicative
layout the house to the right that house
and the area where the photographs has
been taken does not form any part of the
application site it's within the blue
land that is the area that's currently
affords access to the building that you
can see there the Green Building and the
car parking area where cars are stored
in connection with an internet Car Sales
business
thanks Amy
I'm just that's just panning around
further to the west and across the site
because members can note the the poplar
trees in that photograph then this these
um next panel Panorama of slides jet is
the area where permission has been
granted
um in most part for housing so the area
that you can see there is part of the
site where consent has been resolved to
be granted for housing but the section
106 has not been signed so the
permission that was resolved to be
granted for that part to the site for
five houses is still not granted if you
can sweep round to the next slide Amy
please we're now looking towards the
houses on Spring Gardens in the distance
and in the very Apex of this field so
you can just see in the center left
there that is the location for the
Village Hall at the rest of that site
has extant permission for housing
subject to the area that that field that
I've just mentioned that it's got a
resolution to Grant permission is not
actually being granted
thanks Amy that's just uh the further
extent of that same field you can now
just see the houses on winstein screen
there this is taken from the point at
the
um very southern tip of the site so
those are houses built on the former
nursery and they can price Spring
Gardens houses on the left are
traditional housing and within
Westington Village and if you just to
tear to the next slide Amy we're now
panning ground to the West so where that
um beyond that hedge is where the
Village Hall would be and the access
into the village hall and the extant
housing is just beyond that 40.
the access into the Village Hall just
beyond the 40 mile an hour sign and the
new housing on windsteins green on the
right hand side and you can just see a
photo and a footpath formed inside the
Hedge that's referred to in
representations and then goes along the
the frontage of those houses to the
access into the housing site thanks Amy
and looking back now this is um three
photographs taken from the
Point opposite the existing access into
the site that's looking South towards
Westington Village the new housing wind
stains green on the left-hand side
thanks Amy
that's looking into the site from the
position that we've just seen those
photographs and those are the popular
trees that I've referenced and then Amy
if you will
next slide is looking towards Matlock
those houses and that complex on the
left which includes the petrol former
petrol filling station that doesn't form
part of the the application site the
application site then re-emerges beyond
that house on the center left of the the
photograph
and finally we go to the northern tip of
the site this is the the field where the
hotel was originally proposed there's no
longer development Pros in this field
save for the access and the access roads
to serve the parking areas and then
further into the site the other uses if
you can just go to the next one Amy
please
if you recall I mentioned a Hedgerow on
the very first photographs that we
looked at the Hedgerow just in the
middle left is the Hedgerow that I
referred to and beyond that is where the
lodges would be located this side of the
Hedgerow is where the parking to serve
the The Lodges and the play area for
those facilities would be located and
then if we just pan around the next
slide
this is the back of the existing
buildings that would be converted so you
can imagine just across this field is
where the new roadway would be formed
with the main access going to the left
of those buildings as we looked so the
car parking for the
um Garden sales and Farm Shop with a
subsidiary access going to the right
which would serve the car parking for
the lodge accommodation
thanks Amy
and now if you remember at the start of
the presentation I mentioned about the
notional line across the road the 40 50
mile an hour differential this is taken
from that point so the new access that's
proposed would be into this site just in
the center of this Photograph so through
that hedge where the new
um uh access would be formed and so the
access and the appropriate visibility
displays would need to be formed which
is set out in the report in the office
of you would um alter the
characteristics of this part of the site
with that level of infrastructure to
achieve access into the site that's
where the new access into the proposal
would be formed and that is not a matter
reserved for consideration at any later
date that is where the access would be
and formed should consent be granted
subject to conditions which restrict the
final and exact detailing of that
thanks Amy
and that's looking in the direction of
Matlock from approximately that point
you can just see there the signs which
show the change from the notional
apologize from the 40 miles to the 50
mile an hour speed restricted zones
and then just so the next slide is
looking in the other direction that's
looking towards Westington from that
point
so there would be some impact on the the
hedgerowee to create the necessary
visibilities plays then just find the
chair and three photographs I think
there's three photographs just taken
looking from
um the pointer where the poplar trees
start which on the right hand side so
not quite within the application side
we're looking back out towards the new
housing at windsteins Green I think if
you just scroll through the next two as
well Amy they just show the Panorama of
that that Vista
thank you chair that's the uh the
presentation
thank you for that Adrian I'm now going
to invite the speakers to speak they'll
each have three minutes to get over
their points they'll be informed by 30
seconds remain
as members you can ask them to clarify
any matters that have not been raised
but remember your questions should only
relate to the points which they have
already made and finally if the
technology fails us we have asked them
to send us in advance and written
statements of their comments and these
have been included in the late comments
reports
so uh my first speaker in alphabetical
order I have uh I'm sorry
the first speaker is the board member
councilor Charlotte kupik
on
yes she was there
bye thank you
thank you also if you'd like to stop
thanks Jeff
um so I think he's a very significant
proposal so I thought it important for
me to speak as board member to summarize
the key issues and what's at stake here
there are several aspects of this
application that can't be disputed zones
A and B for new housing in the village
hall have previously been approved so
essentially both of these can be built
almost now if wished whilst they can no
longer be disputed it also goes that I
failed to see how the provision of a
village hall should have any bearing or
weight in overriding concerns over the
scale of other parts of this current
application
so the issues and the basis of the
objection for me arise for me from a few
of the other major aspects which has
been somewhat of a shifting picture but
it's namely now the proposed holiday
lodges and additional highways entrances
These funds are proposing two new
accesses alongside the existing one onto
very dangerous Matlock Road to me
there's been no justification put
forward for the creation of that
proposed new top access there's a lack
of detail around it and I'm incredibly
concerned that that new access would be
hazardous as it's just for the winding
point of the road I hope it's also not
just me that sees the irony here of the
proposals to invest in highways
solutions to try to mitigate problems
that this development would massively
aggravate I also think the creation of a
new formal access here would damage and
urbanize the currently clearly rural
character as you enter and exit The
Village which is also the entrance and
exit to our district
in a similar way the proposed holiday
lodges under Zone G would also cause I
think irreparable harm to what is
currently valued green fields and
sloping Countryside even the neighboring
Council Amber Valley has highlighted
that this proposal is inherently
unsustainable which cause harm to the
rural landscape and will be better
suited to be near a level one settlement
Westington is level three and it's
devastating to me that whilst these
proposals are trying to establish a
rural holiday destination if their past
they'd actually damage what they're
trying to promote
with this given that these are such
drastic proposals and is granting
permission today albeit in outline would
confirm the principle of these plans
I've got grave concerns over the detail
we're currently being presented with
this application has changed wildly from
what was first submitted which included
the Hotel and Spa and the plans have
constantly been changing further right
up to further amended plans just two
weeks ago which apparently removed
proposals for housing in zone C for now
there's incredibly limited information
on the latest plans and many statutory
Consultants as you can see from Pages
five and six of your report have raised
concerns as one example there's no
information on how the holiday lodges
would be used or detailed plans for them
many residents fear these could
eventually be houses in Disguise
therefore I have to conclude that this
is a very speculative substantial
proposal which would have a
transformative effect on the small rural
Village of Westington I really tried to
weigh this up but given the considerable
scale of the proposals and the impact
they would have on the open Countryside
I can't conclude the plans would be a
good or positive transformation but I
urge the committee to refuse this
application thank you chair
has anybody got any questions because
hello oh Council hall and then cancel
the following
yeah hello
yeah good afternoon uh councilor DuPage
uh you've got concerns regarding the
highways but uh in our notes it says the
DCC have not objected to it would would
you in your opinion then would you
rather see less accesses on no accesses
whatsoever uh the other point is
considering that there is already
planning application on on this site uh
do you do you consider what is proposed
excessive to what is already
um in place what what has been granted
um thanks Jed you want me to answer yeah
yeah thank you
um thank you councilor Hall yeah I think
it's
um I think my view is you know as I say
lots of parts of this application have
already been approved
um as I mentioned a and C The Village
Hall the housing and also
um the actual Brownfield site of the
Proctor development uh well currently
the Proctor cars so I've not really got
a problem with those I think it's the
the rest of it essentially particularly
the holiday lodges and the creation of
the additional accesses to feed those
holiday lodges and potentially other
things in the future that make this
excessive
um and that's that's why I think as I've
mentioned in my speech I have tried to
weigh this up
um but I think overall this is too
excessive for the area
um just in terms of the highways
question that you asked
um I guess that that's over to highways
I think councilor Barry Lewis has
submitted comments which the chair is
reading all the Clarks reading uh later
on and I think he's commented more
specifically on the highways issues
because he's been looking into that
um but I just think that in that
position whilst highways haven't
objected my local opinion on it and I
know the opinion of local residents is
that that additional top access is a
step too far
um and we'll create a lot more issues
than it will solve as well as having
rule damage
and I think that's everything
um thank you
um against the Cooper you you mentioned
the the
um the Village Hall which has already
been
um approved could you could you just
give some context to that in relation to
why it is now included in this one
um yeah there's there's quite a long
history on the Village Hall uh and I
think a few of the speakers are going to
sort of expand on that further so they
may be better uh sort of placed because
they've been directly involved but as
far as I'm concerned I have no problem
with the you know the installation of a
village hall I think that that's fine if
people want it but I'm not sure that the
extent of the rest of this development
is an appropriate price to pay for the
village and it has already got
permission or previously had uh you know
resolution to Grant planning committee I
think it was Adrian might be able to
clarify but I think it was about five or
six years ago when the housing was
passed so the principal of a Village
Hall
has been approved in the past therefore
if the the applicant wants to get on and
do it that's fine but I don't understand
why you need 50 holiday lodges to
accompany that that's probably reducing
thank you Council Cooper any more
questions regards looking for
thank you for the next uh the next week
and next person over on my list is
Charles Alex
[Music]
there you go hello can you hear me hello
Mr owlette yes we can hear you loud and
clear
um if you'd like to stop
um now you can do please okay good
afternoon I was one of the Steering
group of six who after three and a half
years of hard dedicated work help
deliver the Westington neighborhood plan
owned by The Village reflecting its
views with a 96 vote in favor the
highest turnout in Northeast Derbyshire
at the time Wessington has grown in size
by 42 in the last few years and its
residents have had enough to quote the
planning inspector at ruling on the 23rd
of March 2018 on back Lane the continued
unplanned expansion of Wessington
Village into the countryside would not
preserve the environment and would not
in my opinion improve the quality of
life for the local community
your own Northeast Derbyshire council
plan
2019-23 in your aims State enhancing our
residence quality of life and protecting
and promoting the character of our
district all this conflicts with this
monster of the plan the school is
heavily oversubscribed with no room for
expansion and there is no direct bus
service to other villagers to quote the
same planning inspector it's clear from
Derbyshire County Council consultation
the school will not have the capacity to
accommodate the projected three pupils
that's just three pupils once the
holiday Lodgers have become permanent
homes The Village has no supportive
infrastructure
I would remind you that the reserve
matters meeting on the 3rd of December
2019 some counselors on the planning
committee openly said They wish they'd
not originally agreed to the housing on
part of this Greenfield side
therefore let's not approve this
application which would take a lot more
of our Countryside and green fields
The Village has overwhelmingly rejected
the village hall on several occasions by
voting the parish council and please see
their detailed letter of objection on
the 14th of August a professional survey
and the neighborhood plan questionnaire
this project is only supported by a very
small group who have no evidence of any
significant support the village agrees
the price to pay is too great and must
be disregarded
we have now had our first fatal accident
in the village on Matlock Road and very
many shocking incidents also one stretch
embankment on the same side as the
proposed development is only 94
centimeters wide
hundreds of extra Vehicles generated by
this proposal with all the extra noise
and pollution and the increased
potential for further child fatalities
fills the village with horror this of
course is just phase one and conflicts
totally with the neighborhood plan your
own council plan and earlier planning
inspector rulings please reject this
major plan and thank you for listening
to me yes
thank you very much Mr Alex any
questions for Mr Alex
no
right thank you very much for your
importance Charlotte
we'll move to the next speaker the next
speaker is Jenny Hill
Jenny Hill
is she not here yeah
thank you if you'd like to start you've
got three minutes from now again thank
you
um good afternoon
the a615 runs directly through the
village of Westington
um it is an extremely busy fast and
noisy stretch of road Westington has a
history of concerns regarding the
highway which have been raised on a
number of number of occasions with local
councilors in the highways Department
including pedestrian difficulties
dangerous overtaking speeding and Noise
the stretch of road to the southern
aspect of the village also saw a
fatality in 2019
the scale of the proposed retail and
tourist accommodation is likely to
create considerable vehicle movements
including light and heavy Goods Vehicles
putting further pressure on this
difficult stretch of highway and
increasing traffic noise for residents
the parish council and local councilor
are currently working with the highways
Department to raise concerns Associated
specifically with this section of the
road where the developer plans to create
two new additional access points
the completion of the whistones green
development which sits directly opposite
the application site has already
exacerbated existing highways issues in
the village residents of Western's green
development have already reported
numerous incidents to the parish council
including over 15 near misses and two
actual collisions in a single 12-month
period
mostly related to Residents pulling into
or out of the Housing Development
the lack of consideration for
sustainability within the application of
the and of the location will create a
Reliance on car travel to and from the
site
Villages serviced by a limited bus
service there is no provision for
cycling and the site has no feasible
pedestrian routes to ensure linkage and
integration with the village
indeed the development sits almost in
isolation from the natural Village
Center the northern access point will
cross farmland and extend approximately
800 feet from the settlement development
limit on the edge of a 50 mile per hour
Zone
in order to provide adequate visibility
display large sections of native and
mature hedgerows and trees will need to
be removed significantly changing the
visual appearance approach
approach and appearance of the village
80 Seconds an overhood plan States
future development must ensure that it
does not exacerbate the existing
highways difficulties despite this the
application lacks detail and thorough
assessment thinking that it contains no
mitigations to assess address concerns
outlined those within the neighborhood
plan or those raised by the highways
Department
so in summary the scale of the
application is not in keeping with the
infrastructural characterist village
three minutes
has anybody got any questions for Jenny
Hill
no all right I'd like to thank you for
the second time article was speaking to
us today okay so the next person I have
um on my list is councilor by Lewis
yes chair he's unable to be um at the
meeting today uh would you'd have liked
it to her attend us
um but was asked um for his text to be
read out uh shall I do that now and can
you still hear me or would it be better
to have someone else
shall we uh ask anything
thanks
so this is from councilor Barry Lewis
unfortunately I cannot be there for this
application but who would make the
following points this application is
clearly using the outline application
process to mask a multitude of
complexities ill thought out aspects
core design and layout poor access
egress to the development does not
address grade national and local targets
to reduce CO2 and in my opinion is
trying to establish a precedent for high
density development that could be
changed on subsequent iterations and
applications to potentially remove
lodges in favor of houses and so on
whilst I accept that the committee can
only judge the application before you
name elements of what I've pointed out
are not considered material I would
challenge back that in the spirit of
sustainable development this application
would fail that test for the community
of Westington our Peak French
Countryside and impact adversity on our
local highways infrastructure and
significantly increase CO2
I can accept that there are established
elements to the development including
some housing The Village Hall and a
local shop from a previous successful
application and I can even accept and
welcome some aspects of the development
that will provide and much needed
broadly but not essentially locally
where we have some over Supply tourism
accommodation and employment
opportunities to the locality
however developments that seek to
provide high quality tourism and
accommodation complexes are usually well
thought out with well-considered
Landscaping have a well-considered
internal layout of an appropriate
density give thoughts to sustainability
and to providing green transport
infrastructure for cycles and other
low-carbon transport this clearly fails
all those tests I therefore would
challenge the green credentials of this
application which clearly relies on all
its businesses to come by car
given the very ambitious targets set by
all Derbyshire councils including neddc
to reduce CO2 and encourage sustainable
tourism and transport this application
fails
I would also reiterate that there is no
sense of ownership of the proposals or
credible public facing entity to
essentially build and deliver any of
this an important consideration for
local resident and local Authority
confidence as well as the ongoing
sustainability of the project
I would also make the point that the
landowner slash developer to date
despite being granted permission to
build housing and a successful bid to
the National Lottery scheme has so far
failed to deliver either the housing or
a village hall and dismayed that this is
being considered as an outline planning
application for all the reasons I've
described this clearly should be a full
and detailed application to address many
key issues that have become apparent in
this week speculative application
further the application in the context
of the fast-moving situation with the
graduate National local government plans
producing CO2 and decarbonizing the
economy is out of date finally I would
point out I should understand that
Derbyshire CCC as the highways Authority
have raised significant stands in their
email to Adrian date 10th of August and
remain unpublished on board
so we shall move on to the next speaker
that's okay and I've got the next
speaker down as being a Mr David crooks
on behalf of Mrs Crooks
yes chair unfortunately Mr Crooks I was
having internet connectivity problems so
he provided a written copy a handwritten
copy of his text uh unfortunately we've
not actually we've only just received
this and so we've not been able to send
it to members so I'll have to read it
out I'm afraid so hopefully the uh the
microphone will hold up so I'll begin at
the moment
dear says I'm writing up behalf of Mrs
Crooks at lindway Cottage as we had
limited access to the internet
this letter contains the same issues as
the previous ones as we thought the
first application was out of proportion
for a small village
we are against the plan if it encroaches
too much onto the Greenbelt Land which
we have quite which has a quite a
diverse habitat
other concerns is the road Junction
traffic will have to be slowed down
considerably as some vehicles are
traveling far too fast through the
village
residents will know all about the racing
and overtaking on Junctions
the other concern is the amount of
lodges being built
could there be a safety risk such as
fire
I've just seen the revised plans and
it's good to see some of the land will
be made over to Parkland
and it signed Yours Faithfully D Crooks
and Mrs E H Crooks thank you
thank you
Again difficult to take questions as if
they're not here to answer them so I
shall move on to the next speaker
do I have done with a Tim Hugh Louis if
we'd like to confirm who you are Mr
Lewis yes good afternoon
um can you hear me all right yes we can
so you've got three minutes from now to
put your points across and you'll be
reminded 30 seconds before long okay my
family and I have lived in Western for
over 15 years and in that time we've
seen the village increase in size and
altering character dramatically I object
to this application for the following
reasons we live to the south of the site
and adjacent to the western part of the
proposed development label the sector G
on the plans this is a large area with a
high density of lodges 32 in total which
stretch down the 10 meter slope towards
the existing stream and pond
this is an existing Wildlife Corridor
with the stream forming a valuable
habitat for the abundance of insects
animals that live in the nearby Woodland
scrubbing Fields house buzzards deer
foxes badges Etc live here there will be
a direct impact on this delicate
ecosystem it is my belief that the
disruption caused by such developments
is not immediately apparent and is only
after several years once the irreparable
damage to the local ecology has occurred
that the full impact can be assessed we
begin to read the decisions made years
earlier I do not believe that ecological
impacts have been investigated
thoroughly enough
I'm equally concerned about surface
water discharge from the site into the
pond and stream which would both
increase the flow and alter the nature
of the stream flowing through brow wood
and further along into the Amber Valley
potentially causing flooding the
properties at Westington hay and Beyond
the original flood risk assessment
carried out in 2018 suggests the need
for some form of water attenuation on
the western half of the site as Soca
waves are unlikely to be sufficient
and propose the storage volume of
approximately 2 700 cubic meters for a
100 Year event the original plans on
this time did include for the creation
of a lake presumably for this purpose
which appears to have been taken off the
later scheme without any obvious
alternative solution in its place I
don't believe enough has been done to
address these important issues
secondly I'm concerned about the visual
aspect of the scheme concerns that have
already been raised by the development
control landscape architect the most
recent report from April 19 highlights
the inadequacy of the ZTV analysis in
that it does not consider views from
slack Lane more and more Lane by Pond
Farm or the southern end of footpath
Westington
ne2361 and questions the assessments of
views One and Two from Matlock Road
looking North and South the current
assessment is stated as a moderate
impact and in the opinion of the
landscape architect this should be
revised to Major to properly reflect the
effect that the proposed development
will have upon these views and likely on
those other views not currently
considered
finally be it residential houses a shop
Village Hall or lodges or all of the
aforementioned which this site could
become this is a large-scale development
spreading into green fields which is not
adjacent to the core of the village and
is not in line with our neighborhood
plan if it were to be allowed it may set
a precedent for allowing further
development between this site and the
existing houses which would turn
Westington into more of an urban sport
than a rural Village and that's all
thank you
thank you very much has anybody got any
questions
no thank you very much Mr P Lewis
foreign
thank you very much
for three minutes thank you good
afternoon Ben Elder live off uh lindway
Lane at Westington
um I'd like to emphasize three points if
I may uh firstly
um the the development is
um extends into the uh
settlement area it's it's um the
application is clearly contrary to
planning policy the majority of the site
lies outside the settlement development
limits and they draw your attention
particularly the council's objections to
the local plan uh in chapter four
spatial strategy it states the use of
settlement boundaries is a fundamental
part of the plan strategy it is clearly
distinguishes between the built
framework of settlement where
development is acceptable in principle
and the open Countryside where policies
are more restrictive this gives Clarity
and certainty to all those involved in
the planning process
and then policy ss9 focuses on the
relationship between the neighborhood
plan and the local plan
and states that development would be
permitted outside settlement development
limits if it is a com if it is in
accordance with the uh policy of the
adopted in the local plan
the Westington neighborhood plan does
not allocate any such sites
further a further example of The
Proposal is against the local plan is
contained in gs6 where new development
in Countryside which says new
development in development development
in the countryside will only only be
permitted where
the development is appropriate to such a
location it is in keeping with the
character of the countryside it causes
minimal disturbance to farming it does
not require major infrastructure
provision it causes minimal problems of
noise pollution and other environmental
impacts and it does not represent a
potential intrusion into the countryside
this application fails on all these
policy requirements and would establish
a dangerous precedent if approved
my second point is that the recent
changes in the general permitted
development order which were effective
from the 1st of August 2020 make it
increasingly difficult to ensure that
buildings remain in the use designating
designated in planning applications
it is not clear how the planning
Authority will ensure that this
development doesn't morph into a
residential use
my third point is on covid-19 and
covid-19 has changed all of our lives
and including uh the the viability of
local shops
there were concerns about the viability
of the community shop and the Village
Hall before the pandemic but now with
the extra costs associated with cleaning
should social distancing and uh uh the
increased legal responsibilities it's
extremely unlikely the shop will
actually open
I would also like just to inquire from
the planning officers of whether all the
agencies have been recontacted since the
last plans were submitted on the 18th of
August and if so what their outcomes
were
thank you thank you
has anybody got any questions for Mr
Elder
no
thank you very much thank you
um I am one last person speaking against
a lot is Kevin Ryan
[Music]
can you hear me
yes
oh okay good afternoon Kevin Ryan
Washington has been discussing the pros
and cons of a village hall for over 40
years I hope as a member of the
Westington neighborhood plan Steering
group I can persuade you to see today
that once again developers are using the
offer of a village hall as a major
support tool for their development plan
I must clearly state right now that a
large percentage of Washington residents
do not want a village hall if it means
supporting this huge and obviously
phased application
in 2011 the spring gardens development
by Ben Bailey at Westington
was granted planning approval with a
village hall and Shop
a document produced by RPS on behalf of
Ben Bailey Homes subsequently stated
there was clearly a lack of support for
a village hall and the planning
committee that Northeast Derbyshire
agreed to amend the development with
additional housing
the position was supported by comments
that were received at the time of the
original outline application from
Westington Parish Council which stated
that a Community Hall was not needed for
the village as there was already a
church Hall and that the village could
not support additional retail unit
concerns were also raised over the
future maintenance of such a facility
The Proposal that you are considering
today has been going round in various
forms since 2016.
every one of these proposals has used
the argument that by agreeing to the
planning proposal Worthington will have
a Village Hall
in March 2019 the parish council held a
meeting to discuss this application well
over 50 residents attended the meeting
and had an opportunity to air their
concerns
a high turnout for a small village like
Washington
every single person at the meeting
disagreed with the application and
equally every person questioned the need
for a Village Hall
there is a village hall in brackenfield
less than a mile away which struggles to
maintain reasonable occupancy
Village Halls are traditionally run by
the Parish Council on behalf of
residents the Westington Parish Council
has never had any involvement in this
proposal for the Village Hall
there is a small group of people who
would like to see a village hall in
Wessington some are obviously the four
individuals who have written supporting
this planning proposal
this is compared to the 69 seconds of
written objecting to The Proposal
the thought of spending 500 000 pounds
of Lottery money on a building may seem
an exciting prospect to some people but
we all know that a village hall requires
a sound business plan with sufficient
income generation to support running
costs if you talk to anyone in the
village no one has seen any type of
business plan to support the continued
costs in maintaining the running of such
a building I ask you as the planning
committee to understand
do not see the benefits of a village
hall when it is linked to this totally
out of proportion and phased application
for the size of wettington thank you
thank you
well that's the last of the appearances
that I have that wish to speak
um I now have another in support of the
application
uh wishes to speak on it so remember you
can ask them to clarify any matters that
they have been raised but your question
should only relate to the points that
they have already made
excuse me chat and excuse me Chad this
is
um I'm a supporter for the scheme a
person called Paul Emerson who um has
confirmed that um he's going to have
internet difficulties
um with Wi-Fi so he's asked for um us to
read out his um his statement okie dokie
is that Simon well uh is that going to
be you or
um
it's quite a long um statement this one
so actually it might be wise if I start
off just so that we can actually apply
the uh the three minute rule on this
yeah okay I'm just comfortable with that
okay
um please see the statement from the
trustees of the Westington Village Hall
Trust the lottery awards at a grant of
500 000 pounds to build a village hall
including the shop in Westington because
there was a demand in the village for a
village shop at Village uh for the
village and Shop hence planning was
granted at that time
although this money was awarded six
years ago it is still available
due to the nature of the project and the
fact that the hall has always been part
of a Housing Development the trust has
until November 2020 the spend this grant
after this it will be too late and the
money will be will be withdrawn
there were many questions or any
questionnaires over the years the latter
ones being in 25 20 2005 2011 and 2012
and 2014.
on the basis of these which showed
overwhelming support for the village
shop or for a village hall I should say
a bid was put together or a grant from
the lottery to build a village hall and
Shop which was successful
the lottery in doing their own due
diligence awarded the money having seen
all the facts and voices of the
villagers
we need to be mindful of the epidemic of
crime that affects the Youth of today
there are a number of residents very
keen to run clubs for all ages getting
young people off the streets especially
in the winter months
having lived in the village for over 17
years I've been able to see the changes
and growth of this very special place
the prospect of getting this longer
waited Haul is fantastic
we have a growing young population of
children who are now at the age when
playing out alone on the public park on
Coronation Street is an option
as the village grows with another
development bringing in another 60
houses this will mean even more young
people
having worked in children's services for
over 30 years I'm fully aware of the
need to give young people a place where
they can get out of the house but be
safe around volunteers who are DBS
cleared and can offer activities or just
a base to meet
the parish council have previously been
well aware of this element of the
village Hall's function
the pasture being part of the Village
Hall committee and trustee for a period
of time which to me is confusing given
their current stance and reported
inaccurate statements not reflecting the
voice of the village in a positive way
my goal committees The Village Hall
committee has changed over the decades
several of those who are passionate
about the Village Hall have sadly passed
away before their dream came to fruition
the current trustees have been in place
for the last five years so much longer
in 2014 the questionnaires show that
there will be more support for many
activities at the Village Hall including
brownies Cubs minions or soccer ball
mites Etc
The Village Hall committee have been in
communication with the doctor said
we can't hear you all I'm sorry
The Village three minutes
you want me to just actually continue
for a few seconds longer Birmingham on
those connectivity issues the majority
of the way through it so I I think we
might as well hear the rest of the uh
The Village Hall committee have been
Communications
right I think actually can you hear me
Nacho I can hear you now yes yeah
um The Village Hall committee have been
in communication with the doctor's
surgery to get covered in the village a
couple of days a week using the
facilities of the Village Hall
and we're also planning to install an
ATM machine
um there's a bundle of a half page of
comments here do you want me to continue
I think we've probably heard enough of
that one and you've had a good bash at
it so I think we'll leave that from
there
it is in the park no other members
thank you
right so you heard all the speakers
said our colleagues you have the
opportunity to put questions
um
sorry where am I yeah you've got to the
planning manager and other officers
about the application
I would like to keep this part of our
proceedings focused on getting clarity
about the points that you are not sure
of
once we've done this we can then have
our discussion about the application
based on all three of bird
for that reason members I would be
grateful if you could not move any
motions at this stage and let's wait
until we have our hope the chance to
make our own assessment again the same
rule applies please mute your likes
unless you wish to speak
have you got any questions for the
plumbing officers
father
hope is going forward
no no questions Jen no questions
right so I'll move on I will open the
floor for the debate again could any of
you please respond from moving any
motions until we've completed our
discussions
so if you'd like to welcome to debate
councilor Armitage and councilor
shipment
foreign
this application is uh well in my mind
uh the village Hall's already been
approved and nothing actually done uh
and there appears to be great to
resistance to have a very tall
when it comes down to uh the actual I
don't think that it is a sustainable uh
development it's outside the settlement
development limited limits and it's a
new development in the countryside well
I think you've got to look at the
Westington neighborhood plan which uh
you've got it mentions the protection of
the natural environment and Landscape uh
character Washington uh is a great three
uh settlement and it's not a grade one
which uh it's it's uh clearly needs to
be to sustain this
the road has been brought into question
the road is an extremely fast Road and
uh you know it is an accident well there
have been accidents uh and this uh the
access of the new development is uh in
my mind completely in the wrong area so
that's what I think
Council Shipman
thank you chair um like Council Armature
said this is outside the uh settlement
limits and it's adding the substantial
development to what is a small rural
town a village sorry if you look at the
the amount of objectives here and not
just the the members of the public who
obviously live there but if you look at
the statutory console teams you've got
environmental health have contamination
issues about the land that's already
there Derbyshire County Council
strategic planning are against it
garbage County Council Landscape
Architects are against it ECC Urban
Design are against it the police have
security issues because the uh
accommodation is too far away from the
parking so they've not supported it and
the vallebora council against it
um seven Trend
um they want to see the plans to
discharge water and sewage they've not
provided that as far as I can see in
this pack Derbyshire Wildlife trust
against it the parish council against it
Westington neighborhood the plant
Steering group which have obviously been
involved in Consulting with members of
the public to developed the neighborhood
plan they're against it the developers
have not consulted with the Steering
group at all
I'm I I I I'm honestly shocked actually
that the planning office have
recommended this to be accepted because
everything if you read all the documents
it's contrary to that position actually
if anything we should be saying no way
on Earth this is going ahead
uh based on what I can see I mean to
call it a sustainable development is we
keep getting these coming to the planet
where people say I've got the
sustainable development they've planted
two trees and then they can get away
with calling a sustainable development
it has to meet certain objectives it has
to be an economic benefit to the local
area for it to be a sustainable it has
to be a social benefit to the local area
I'm not sure visitors coming to a spa
resort uh adding towards Community
cohesion they're they're Outsiders if
you like coming to us particular to
enjoy a holiday that's not bringing the
community together there also has to be
an environmental object which I don't
see I don't see you know uh solar panels
everywhere I don't see you know wind
turbines and stuff that can actually
help the environment objectives that's
supposed to within the sustainable
development so I I can't see how I can
support this development at all it's
just adding such a significant
development to the side of Westington
it's almost another third
um the size of Westington and I just
think that we have to object to this and
not prove it
thank you very much
Adrian you wanted to come in yeah just a
view of um counter Shipman's comments I
didn't think it'd be useful if I could
seek to um clarify the view of officers
and why we've recommended approval chair
but It ultimately cancel the shipment is
absolutely right that you need to
consider this development and as to
whether it achieves violent sustainable
development weighing up environmental
social and economic strands ultimately
that's the consideration before you just
in terms of some of the points have been
made sure and I'll pressures clearly
acknowledge that the site is outside the
settlement development limit for
Westington but as we've discussed on
many occasions
um I would urge caution on members
placing too much Reliance on sdls even
in this case because of the elderly
nature of the the council's local plan
but also bear in mind that tourist
development by its definition will not
generally be within settlement
development limits and we'll need to
occupy a rural area
just in terms of the the issue that um
cancerologies made in terms of the
countryside protection National
environment absolutely chair members
need to take a view on whether this
development in this location is
appropriate in terms of its impact on
the the Greenfield nature of the site
and clearly any development has an
impact on the Greenfield nature of this
site but you need to weigh up whether
that is harmful or not bearing in mind
the area for The Lodges and whether you
can condition those as recommended to be
single story for example whether the
landscaping that's proposed to mitigate
any adverse impacts just in terms of the
the comments that capture shipment made
about some of the Consultants chair just
to ask members to bear in mind that some
of those comments were made on the
originally originally submitted scheme
which is larger in scale than that now
proposed chair and officers
recommendation is based on the
um most up-to-date scheme which has most
recently lost the the housing elements
but pre-consultation didn't take place
on that chair because that was clearly
something that reduced any impact of the
scheme and those commenting on the the
scheme that was amended earlier this
year would only be embedded by that
chair
um just finally if I may on the issue of
Darbyshire Wildlife for us the comments
made by darshua like trust raised
concerns about the level of information
that was submitted to support the
application but only in so far is it
related to the location of the
development feeling that further
information was needed to actually
address the issue of final location of
all the various elements and that's why
officers have taken the view that that
in this case isn't overriding but again
members will need to take a view on
whether that level of information is
sufficient to allow you to to proceed in
terms of um actually determine the
application in favor of it you may
consider there's not enough information
and you may consider that sufficient on
its own to resist the application along
with or without other elements
um and just just finally Chad just in
terms of the the development plan
members will be aware that the
Westington neighborhood fund does form
part of the development plan but that
does indicate that at least part of the
site would be appropriate for tourism or
commercial Redevelopment laws as members
to to bear that in mind chair thank you
thank you Adrian has anybody got any
more questions I don't want to discuss
before we move on
no
right so we've heard everything there so
I know I've made it to the floor for a
motion so everybody wanted to put a
version forward councilor Armitage
Council shipment
yeah I'd like to put the motion forward
to go against office's recommendation uh
the reasons mean that uh it's against uh
gs1 uh sustainable development uh it's
also uh it's outside GS5 the settlement
development limits uh and gs6 it's a new
development in the countryside
uh any one landscape character and also
the Wessington neighborhood plan because
it should protect the natural
environment and Landscape character
which this
certainly does not it's a massive scale
uh and we should vote against this
Council shipment I absolutely second
every word of council armitage's uh
motion all right thank you very much
right remember so we've got some motion
but we've always before we move to the
Vault I'd like the plant to read it out
so that we're all clear about what we're
actually voting for
Mr chair as I understand it the motion
is
um to reject uh the application country
to offer to recommendations uh with the
focus for the reasons for rejection
being around sustainable development the
fact that the development would be
outside the settlement limits and that
it would be a new development within the
countryside and if Adrian wants to
comment on that
apologies chair just need to unmute
myself um yes in noting the um the um
motion chair
um policies gs1 GS5 which is normally
set in development within settlement
development limits
um whether cancer Armitage is sure he
wants to include reference to that
policy in his motion share in terms of
gs6 I understand that and certainly
anyone and the Western neighborhood and
the relevant policies from their chair
but I would would ask members if they
would also want to um
um in view of cancer architecture
comments about the impact on the
character of the area whether they would
also wish to add words um that are taken
from the national planning policy
framework in terms of and protecting and
enhancing the natural environment for
example because I get the feeling from
the debate that it is that the scale and
nature of the development that is
concerning to cancer armor teaching
councilor shipment and its impact on the
the natural language environment which
is
um the character of the air which is
policy me1
again chair if
um if members are minded to to refuse
the application in accordance with the
motion share when they vote and perhaps
I could ask that delegated powers are
given to myself in consultation with
yourself to finalize the exact wording
of the reasons reason for refusal chair
thank you Adrian is that okay my account
is wrong with surgeon Council Shipman
yeah
thank you
all right then so if we can move to the
vote and we'll do this again through a
roll call
this chair asked for our read everyone's
name happy and just clearly indicate for
against or abstain
councilor and cliff
here's the application
so it's safe for the motion but yes yeah
cancer Armitage four
councilor Barry form
Casper Cooper for Chancellor Foster
four thank you councilor Hall
[Music]
councilor Huckabee
girls
councilor pots
oh
councilor Powell or
antonographs
oh
and councilor Shipman for
that's everyone in voting in favor chest
that motion is carried to refuse the
application
thank you for that anyway
um
right so the motion's been approved
um so thanks for that
um
so that's that's good thank you very
much everybody so the next part on the
agenda
is item five which is around the
planning Appeals
I now call the planning manager to
explain our next report item five the
appeals lodged undetermined
thank you share won't keep members um
more than a couple of minutes on this
but there were just two appeals
reporting in this
um one the chair both were dismissed and
um there's officers we we welcome the
um
dismissal of the two appeals as perhaps
you would imagine particularly in terms
of the prior approval for the conversion
of the bonds share the inspector was
supportive of the council stance that
the prior approval procedure that would
otherwise Grant permitted development
for the change of use of these
agricultural buildings does actually
require some um some discussion and the
level of work can in this case amount to
more than the conversion of the building
so I know members will have received a
copy of this uh this appeal decision but
it is one that takes takes some reading
but it does actually provide a great
deal of support to the center that
officers have moved to and will continue
to look at the proposals with some with
the critical eye and future chair but
um it is supportive as was the appeal at
called the road at drum field of the
officer stances so we welcome them
happily take any questions chair but um
that's all I would have to say on a
limit of the time being
thank you Andrew has anybody got any
questions for Adrian
no right okay so thank you members
um and do we agree to note the reports
from Adrian
yeah not in favor
I think that's everybody
um and the next item is urban business I
haven't already in business remember so
I can now declare this meeting closed
and it is four minutes past five
thanks everyone thank you everybody
thank you